e
e e
good morning
everyone we'll start today's work
session on Thursday February 27th
2024 excuse me
25 not going to go back in time for the
record I am state representative Moren
money of the town of marac I am the vice
chair of division 3 on the house finance
committee our chairman representative
Jess Edwards cannot be with us today but
I'm sure he's watching on
YouTube Today's work session was
published in the house calendar as well
as outside of this room so we do have a
publicly noticed work session just a
reminder that the materials we work from
are found a few places online the LBA
site which is off of the general court
website that's the legislative budget
assistance web
page as well as the department of
administrative Services they have a very
comprehensive web page there of the
materials we work
from our deadline we're looking to get
out our version with amendments and so
forth by the end of March March 26th or
so and then house bills 1 and two should
be out of the Full House by April 3rd
early April I would ask members of the
committee to take notes as we go along
I'm not going to take motions we're not
going to have votes in the division
today and then that the presenters of
course make it clear what page and
accounting unit we're working from as
well as highlighting for us any
prioritized needs and vacancies uh which
have been reoccurring questions uh as we
go throughout these budget
lines all right with that any comments
from our members of division 3 at this
point okay I'm glad to see everybody and
I'm glad everybody arrived safely I know
the weather is not on our side this
morning so I know it took tremendous
efforts of both committee members and
members of the audience and presenters
so we thank you very much uh for making
yourselves available on a snowy morning
to be with us
today the work session
is entitled budget work session division
of Behavioral
Health uh depending on how far we go
this morning we'll consider you know
when to take our lunch break uh you let
us know what's good for you in the 12
12:30 range of things I'm thinking uh
and let us know too if the flow of what
we do questions throughout your
presentation works for you or not we can
always adjust that so with that welcome
to division three and you may start at
your
leisure good morning I'm ktia Fox I'm
the director of the division for
Behavioral
Health good good morning uh Nathan white
Chief Financial Officer of the
Department of Health and Human Services
um this morning uh as as always there's
three documents in front of you um the
first is the PowerPoint presentation
that's the the the colored document
there in front of you there's also the
budget briefing book um for the division
for Behavioral Health and then uh just
as a reminder we talked about this
yesterday the the only accounting units
included in the briefing book are those
in excess of a million dollars annually
and then within the governor's operating
budget we'll be looking at Pages
988 through
104 and with that said I will hand it
over to
K thank you um I want to note that um I
am here to answer your question
questions and hopefully by the end of
our session I'll have been able to do
that if not I also have some staff in
the audience and um we'll ask them to
contribute if they uh have their
responses on the spot and of course
we'll follow up with any um questions
that I we unable to answer today also I
wanted to note that we have about 60
pages to get through um so I know we
have a 6-hour block today with a lunch
break there is one duplicate slide that
is towards the end and I'll point that
out when we get there I also want to
know um as we go through this that we're
going to be looking at some numbers and
you're going to be seeing some
differences between actuals and adjusted
authorized in 24 and 25 and then you're
going to see some significant swings in
26 and 27 and that's because of some
changes that we made in accounting units
so no huge um uh additional funds or
decrease in funds for our Bureau I mean
for our division in the bureaus so with
that I'll start um the as always uh the
department um has each division have a
mission and vision statement and our
mission is to cultivate the mental
health and wellness of all individuals
by promoting thriving and resilient
community in ensuring all people in New
Hampshire have access to highquality
integrated care for Optimum mental
health and our vision is that we have a
Continuum that is individual and family
driven Embraces Innovation and overcomes
challenges is trusted and valued and
brings hope and connection to community
Statewide and I have to say this may
seem just routine oh yeah there's
another mission statement and vision but
this takes lots of time and lots of
discussion among our staff and um with
inputs from our stakeholders so every
single word has been pursed as as we
have put this um before you
today so from a division perspective um
we have oversight and guidance for to
ensure that we have um mental health
substance use in homeless Services
across the state that align
with our mission and our
vision we have technical assistance and
training so we provide that um across
the department as well as other state
agencies and throughout the state and
then we have monitoring and quality
assurance making sure that we have the
data and that we have um that drive uh
what we're doing and that's for all
programs and initiatives and levels of
care
and then of course overseeing our um
programs through our contracts with our
hundreds and hundreds of providers
across the
state so sorry I should say slide
four um so what is the division who is a
division we have four bureaus within our
division we have mental health services
which addresses the adult population we
have children's Behavioral Health
we have the Bureau of drug and alcohol
services and the Bureau of homeless
services and then um sitting side by
side with that is the policy unit um
that looks and um assists across the
entire
division so we have a system of care I
know system of care is used a lot um we
talked about it yesterday with the
system of care for children I know that
there are other areas of the department
that use that but it really is
addressing
comprehensive um care for people across
the lifespan and how do we do that I
mentioned the Contracting we have
Workforce Development training and
technical assistance um the oversight
and performance monitoring
infrastructure development which was key
over the last several years to infuse um
the resources into making sure we have
the Bedrock upon which all of our um
services are built upon and uh policy so
we go through the Continuum we look at
Community Education and awareness
prevention and early intervention peer
recovery which is something that is
really key and important to the work
that we do communitybased supports and
services and then we get to the higher
level of services that are needed for
more complex cases which include
residential treatment and housing
supports crisis services and inpatient
Services um no cuz I wrote my notes on
this um so then on
page
five um we have our positions and where
they fall
on page
six we start going into the accounting
units and um I'm going to probably lean
a little bit on Nathan when it comes to
this but for our 988 Grant which is um
on the budget book page number
988 we have two contracts we have a
contract with headrest which is our our
primary lead for our
Lifeline um for the 988 number that you
call that's the call center and then we
also have a technical assistance um uh
contract with
UNH in the office of the director um
there are no contracts that's where um
my me and my staff uh
sit choose love you may remember this
program from a couple years ago um that
was transferred I believe it was in the
governor's office and then transferred
into our agency sits at the division
level and that is uh
Staffing representative Nano for a
question thank you madam chair uh Miss
Fox U what is the nature of the
technical service with UNH what what do
they provide what does technical mean in
in your world yeah um so they provide um
uh stakeholder um convening so
administrative functions and they do um
continuous process Improvement um when
they look at um the data and um some
data collection for
us so would I be correcting it's kind of
a Consulting Consulting service yeah
yeah I think we call I think we use them
interchangeably so um I can try to
correct for that and and that what is
the what is the value of that
contract I I have it here but I'll need
um maybe during a break I can get it to
you and Nathan's going to look for it
right now thank
you um so uh the next one is the
Medicaid payments to New Hampshire
hospital and glencliffe the these are
the federal funds where they land in our
account from um historic perspective um
and um do not stay within their somewhat
of a pass through and a place where
those funds come
into and then of course unemployment
compensation pay
up representative priest for a question
thank you madam chairman going back to
your program
um Choose Love Can you just Define that
what is that sure so that was a program
um that was established um in the
governor's office um under governor cunu
and it is a program that was born from
the tragedy um in Connecticut with the
school shooting um and so the founder
was a mom um of a child um who was in
that um subject you know who was killed
in that um horrible tragedy and it's
about um building resilience in
communities in schools in children um
and addressing how we can go about um
regulating emotions and um conducting
ourselves in a from a strength-based
perspective rather than um from what was
viewed as a people perspective thank you
just to follow up on that when was that
implemented in New Hampshire that
program how old is
it yeah I I was going to say um New Town
happened about so it happened shortly
after that so about six years ago but we
we can double check thank you
yeah so slide seven
so this again is from a division
perspective about um the key
accomplishments over the last couple
years we have integrated crisis services
available so this isn't just to address
mental health but also to address
substance use
crises um so we have the New Hampshire
rapid response access point and um that
is the centralized location where people
can call for help um when they're
experiencing a mental health crisis or a
substance misuse crisis and it also
deploys the mobile crisis units across
the
state and you can see from the numbers
whenever we had data we tried to include
it in these uh in these slides so that
you had an idea of the scope um and the
reach of these
services and there'll be more data that
I'll be showing a little a little bit
later on we have rapid response crisis
centers so when you look at um the
crisis system you want a place to call
you want someone to respond and you want
um a place to go should you need it and
so there have been two that have been
opened again we'll get a little bit more
into this um a little bit later on and
then we have um something that was in
the last few years that have been
developed which is the cold weather
homeless responses so these are um
either shelters or a way a community can
address the bitter cold winter months um
by opening warming centers and having
other options for people um experiencing
homelessness representative priest for a
question thank you madam chairman and
again I apologize welcome Miss Miss Fox
um back to the rapid response crisis
stabilization centers how many visits
did you have last year I'm going to get
to the data it uh oh for the um the
crisis stabilization Center yes they
have just opened so they just have open
yeah yep they have just opened so um we
have some information about one of them
the other just opened a couple weeks ago
okay what about the cold weather
homeless responses how many uh people I
think I that data later in the deck okay
thank you yeah these um what we tried to
do here was do the highlights and then
we'll go into more details later on in
the
presentation um so another key
accomplishment was we increased housing
options and supports as you know there
has been a real crunch for housing
across the board for everybody um but
despite that we've been able to increase
options for individuals with um a
behavior Al health condition and um
we'll get again these are highlights
we'll get more into the details of the
numbers and what types of housing as we
go
along slide
eight so I know that you've already
heard from Medicaid um as well as DCF so
there's a lot of information that they
shared that also um pops up here and
we've been participating with Medicaid
on um initiatives to improve access to
care and so there was an opportunity
through um our federal partner who is
samsa um as well as through the centers
for Medicare and Medicaid to establish
certified community behavioral health
clinics um these are um clinics that
have um the ability to to serve people
with substance misuse disorder as well
as mental health we have and again we're
going to get into this a little bit
later on in the
presentation and there's a community
re-entry which I believe that director
Litman spoke about um and that's for
having Medicaid services available prior
to someone being released from prison um
so that they are connected to the
community are more likely to um stay and
have Community tenure um with those
Support Services as soon as they um
re-enter the
community um and then we as I mentioned
earlier we have the infrastructure
Investments that we've made so the
one-time funds that we had um we were
able to infuse those into our systems to
um really be uh foundational as we go
forward um right now and again we'll be
talking about these a little bit more we
have an assessment going on for the
children's system of care we had um the
ability to stand up a crisis responder
certification program and so this was a
way to work with our um community
college system and being able to give
the training for the workforce that's
needed to as we expand these
services and we also had a a peer
certification program that was
established representative Neno for a
question yeah thank you madam chair
thank you Mr Fox so could you kind of
describe what the peer certification
program is and and how does that uh how
does that compare to you know uh
professional certification or right so
um we'll get into peer Services um but
the peer certification program is really
to again and give credentials and ensure
that we have the quality that we want
and the delivery um of the workforce and
it gives options for peers for entering
the workforce and having the ability to
be a peer and be recognized as a peer um
in their
setting is that in addition to or in lie
of formal formal training programs
within the uh your
division um it is an addition to thank
you all right so that's that's the
division perspective um and then we're
going to go right into the
bureaus so we're doing pretty well I
think I'm ahead of if I look at uh slide
count and the time we're doing okay so
um I know there was discussion about
this yesterday with the division for
children youth and families okay oh
representative priest for a question yes
going back on the uh peer certification
how are the individuals chosen for this
uh program they choose to enter yeah
yeah yeah just like any other um
certification program that you may want
to take and um be involved in is this
just with the state employees or
businesses no this is for the Community
Based Services and so it allows someone
um who is um a person with lived
experience to go through a training
program and learn how to um have you
know it's all like boundaries and how to
help somebody navigate a system it it's
a lot of that but it's really for the
communities and for our community based
organizations not for the state so you
just make the announcement that you have
this program and okay thank you yes yes
yeah
representative tarki for a question
thanks for taking my question it's just
it's occurring to me that although I
know about the peer support um are these
peer counselors I don't even know what
they're what you call the mentors let's
say are they
volunteers they are not um so the idea
of the certification program is so they
can land a job in the
field
okay thanks
okay so Bureau for children's Behavioral
Health again I know you spoke some of
this um yesterday with director Nan
presenting and so some of it may be
repetitive and I tried to listen in so I
heard some of the questions that came up
and hopefully I can address some of
those so on page
10 you'll see the accounting
units and
um I'm trying to think of where my notes
are not right in front of me for the um
contracts that are affiliated with this
but I think that most of them fall into
2053 so so um one thing I should point
out is you notice there are only two
accounting units so there aren't um a
lot um and that um all of our contracts
fall within I believe the system of
care that's all out of system here yeah
okay um
so the um system of care care account is
where all of our contracted service
appear um and so we contract with our
community mental health centers we
contract with our um Care Management
entities we have New Hampshire rapid
response which I mentioned before um
some of the funds come out of this
account and um our also our
residential programs for children sorry
I need to dial a friend here um and so
um I have 21 pages of contracts by the
way so I printed them out but rather
than fumble through those um I Look to
Nathan instead um so that's where all of
the um children's services are
budgeted representative walner for a
question good time to ask some questions
about the budget
sure so this is just a really quick one
but on on page 1000 I saw that online on
50 you had almost $500,000 worth of
temporary staff during um this this year
and it goes away next
year yes those dollars will not be spent
um I believe I believe what this
represents is from HB
1573 there was a million doll
appropriation that was made and those
funds are non-aps and because of the the
timing and the work and effort that's
required to go through the process to
create positions and then actually hire
those positions and then given the
current status we don't anticipate
spending all of that so that money is
actually being carried forward into this
bium but you're not going to see
necessarily those dollars budgeted here
cuz those those dollars were were
continually appropriated non-lps for
that specific purpose remind me what
was so that is the oversight of the
children's residential and so that Inc
yeah okay yeah and
then when we go down to page 1 10,1 or
1,1 um in your
contracts have is are there any rate
increases for any of the programs
so um as we got through this um we can
sprinkle it throughout or we can do a
summary but there was a prioritized need
for rate increases for residential and
that was not funded um in this current
budget
um I'm sorry it was partially no no that
was in race yeah yeah it was the rate
increases were not funded um and uh the
other thing of note is that um I wanted
to point out because I I figured you
would um pick up on it pretty quickly on
that page of um
1,1 with the total amount in the system
of care in 2053 you see the authorized
adjusted 33.6 million and then it goes
significantly down the reason for that
is because that funding was for um
children's residential rate increases
from the last baym for the current BM
and the all of the uh dollars were put
into this account so this was a way for
us to have an account to deposit all
those funds to account for them they are
now budgeted in the appropriate places
so they're in the Medicaid budget
they're in DCF so we have not had a $10
million cut to Children's system of care
we've had um improved accounting for the
services and and this goes back to our
conversation yesterday where the team's
working on a crosswalk so that we can
give you better insight and and be able
to follow the bouncing ball so to speak
through the three separate account
units there I just have one more about
rates so providers got a rate in um the
bium that we're in but not into the ne
there's no rate increase written in here
for the correct okay thank you and um
there actually is one reduction that I
should just note that the um children's
Behavioral Health Resource Center is not
funded in this budget and so there is
that um about a million dollars that was
reduced in this
budget representative priest for a
question just thank you madam chairman
and just as a followup to the following
question what fund what was the
reduction
yes so again um dispersement of the
about $9 million to other accounts and
then a million dollars for the
behavioral health children's Resource
Center that I'm going to get to when we
you'll see that in one of the
slides okay thank
you representative Nell vano for a
question yes thank thanks uh Madam chair
may maybe you're going to cover this
later but in looking at uh I'm looking
at page 11 on all the various services
so
uh kind of a sensitive subject that's
come to the FL recently is the whole
question of gender
dysphoria and I'm wondering uh how much
of that you're seeing and where it's
covered and how how that manifests
itself in the behavioral uh uh Health
area so I'm not quite sure how to
answered as it pertains to um well the
first question is are are you seeing a
lot lot of that in terms of um uh
Behavioral Health across the wide
spectrum of age groups and gender groups
that you see I would say when you look
at National statistics you can see of
who's at increased risk um for um
suicide um suicide attempts and um
vulnerable
populations that we see some of that
data um that indicates that um there are
certain people who um have have
increased risk and so I don't know how I
would label it other than um there are
some young adults and children who
struggle as a result um and um have
those increased risks so just a quick
follow where does that where does that
fall in terms of the the wheel I'm
looking at on and and and how does that
um um manifest itself in terms of
referrals and other uh aspects of that I
would say that it falls in each one of
these um without any statistics to back
it up um I would say that um when we
start to see it um in as with most uh
communitybased Services It's when um
that you start seeing it on the acute
end when when something becomes a crisis
is when we notice you that you know I'm
just talking in general not specific to
this thank
you all right I guess we're on page 11
um so this is um a a wheel I think
you're getting used to seeing these from
us as we go through the different tiers
and we look at different levels of
services and we always start out with
the populationbased services and then we
um go through the wheel and have the
acute um side going all the way up this
has been something that we've used for
the children's system of care um pretty
much since its Inception what's really
important to note is how many youth are
being served in community- based
settings because we hear about the acute
settings we focus on that but really
most people are being served and youth
are being served in their communities
and as you heard from director Nunan
yesterday about all the efforts to keep
uh Children and Youth in their
communities through kinship care through
their families with family supports and
when necessary through foster
care representative priest for a
question thank you madam chairman do you
have an actual number for this uh that
you said 5% of the youth do you have an
actual number that how many individuals
um we probably yes but I don't have it
here could you also find when you go
back to get that
number the number of you that you have
serviced in previous years to see if
you're getting out to the community and
you're making a difference yeah that's a
that's a really good question when you
look at the data does an increase mean
um is it good because we did a better
job of reaching families or is it an
indication um that we are somehow
failing to provide the services those
Community Based Services so it's always
great to look at the data and then ask
ourselves those questions as as we look
at it and we think about
funding but you will come back with
those actual numbers yeah and you're
going to see them actually in our rapid
response numbers great thank you
okay um this one doesn't have a number
but it's it's
12 and this is looking and further
describing those tiered
services so prevention and uh early
intervention we do the assessment and
evaluation
screenings um and those are looked at as
a universal way to um to that early
identification for
services to the far right you see the
Community Based Services and supports
those are tiers 2 and three and then in
the middle tier tier three as well so
you look at all those types we start
going from a populationbased approach to
the individual based approach and then
start looking at those specialty
services that are needed for specific uh
circumstances
all right slide
13 this is the children's Behavioral
Health Resource Center which um we were
required to stand up and have done so um
that was under um it's now RSA
135f and uh this Center links children
families community members to um the
services and the provider that they need
resources that they need and um the
resource center also provides training
for providers on these issues um
and that's what the center
is representative tarki for a question
so so to clarify you said previously
this is not funded in the governor's
budget correct great thank
you representative n vano for a question
yes thank you madam chair I just want to
come back to page 12 for a second and
and uh ask a couple of quick questions
on a couple of these programs what is
the fast forward program that is a great
question I shouldn't have glossed over
that and again I think we have um some
statistics that indicate um more about
that program it is a high fidelity
wraparound uh service that is for
Children and Youth and it is uh
delivered in the
community so they're individually um
developed through a service plan um with
the family and with those
youth so again I follow up I'm I'm
unfamiliar with a lot of the terminology
yeah but what uh so you mentioned that
that ties into the High Fidelity
wraparound which maybe you could give a
couple of words of uh what that
translates to sure it's coordinating
everybody who's touching a family
and really getting them to all be
working together for the shared goal um
for that
family so it's it's when we say
wraparound it's really not having a
bunch of different places where people
need to go but really having um that
care coordination that needs to happen
uh as people go through the and navigate
the
system and if I may uh one indulge me
for one more on medication manag agement
how uh exactly uh what does that mean uh
does that mean who who are you working
with or who you know what how are you
managing
medications um so I'm going to have to
take that back because I don't know on
the ground exactly how that
happens I do know that um in certain
circumstances um in our community mental
health system the
um medications are dispensed um in a a
um controlled way um with a family to
ensure compliance and or adherence to
dosages and things like that but I can
get um more is it also working with
schools or you know because down here
you have educational and development
services is that the medication
Management in conjunction with I don't
know the school the school system it
could be
yes thank you representative walner for
a question thank you so I heard you say
that the
um Resource Center is not going to be
continued it's not funded in the next
budget right and I wondered could you
talk talk just for a second
about who is that going to
effect
and is the reason it was chosen to not
be funded because it wasn't used or for
what reason was was a decision made that
you wouldn't fund it in the next budget
so um hard decisions are being made
about budgets right now so um I I um not
really going to comment on any one
aspect of our budget and any reduction
um as to why other than we all know that
we're facing a shortfall and re in
revenue and that not everything can
continue as is and so um what we're
thinking um as we go forward is that
this is a service that we could bring
inh housee should we be able to have the
Staffing for it um it's the maintenance
of a website what we lose is the um
provider training specifically um as a
result um
the resource center also is about making
those connections for families in
communities and as you will see we have
a campaign that was pretty successful
known as strong as Granite we need to
think about using such approaches as
well as um what we've used for 988 and
rapid response um in going forward on
how can we reach families and we have
done trainings and we'll continue to do
trainings with our field staff within
DCF and um Juvenile Justice and making
sure that this information is available
for
families thank you representative priest
followed by representative
Stringham thank you Madame chairman um
back to the um the children's Behavior
Health Resource Center how many years
was that in operation and how many
clients did you
serve so I don't I don't think I brought
the um stats on um the numbers but we'll
double check on that I think Nathan's
going to check on that hopefully for me
um it has only been um up and running
for less than two
years I would say I might be wrong on
that but front-facing from a community
perspective I think it's been about two
years as a followup as another question
uh on
page 12 do you have uh actual numbers of
individuals that you served in the
communitybased services and support that
you could share with us yes uh from
20124 and previous five years so yes if
it's not in the briefing book then we
will make sure you get that thank
you uh good morning director Fox good to
see you again thanks for joining us uh
it sounds I didn't see anything uh um
you know later on you talk about your
prior needs and what's been funded and
what's not I didn't see anything on
there on the resource center uh so can
you comment about if it was continued um
what kind of a budget appropriation that
that would uh in involve um thanks sure
and and so what we've what we've tried
to do um at at the request of
Representative walner is include all of
our prioritized needs um that were were
not funded in there um if if it were to
be funded uh what we had originally
budgeted was $1 million of General funds
each year so for a grand total of $2
million over the
bingum uh and um and and there's a
possibility you could bring bring that
work inhouse use uh either available or
additional staff perhaps at a far lower
cost is
that um I I would hope that it doesn't
come to that but yes we would um
consider bringing in inhouse because
it's required by state law that we have
this Center and um we would ask for
additional resources to be able to do
that because as you know um the current
budget unfund positions um and so we're
we're having less staff um and so to
bring something in house requires more
staff um or at least a position to be
filled um the other thing is is the
um ability to um have
that reference technical assistance to
have that uh training for providers that
is not something that we could do in
house so we would lose that um unless we
were able to contract with someone to
provide that and it's really about
looking at um programs that are of high
quality and producing
those and just jumping ahead um
uh how many of the uh 60 or so staff are
unfunded positions right now in this
division sure so so I I I I would have
to manually go through my notes here but
I I can tell you for uh 20052 for
children's Behavioral Health three of
the nine uh full-time authorized
positions you're looking at in in the in
the uh 26 27 budget are currently
unfunded and there's a total of 10
positions across the entire division
that are unfunded
today representative tarki followed by
representative seaworth for questions
thank you quick question um since the
children's Behavioral Health Resource
Center is required by law do you happen
to have the RSA just from our notes or
is that asking too much I believe it
landed in
135f thank
you thank you m M chair um that was
actually my
question as a
followup did the governor's draft of hb2
have to alter or defer that law in order
to adjust the
budget the the the current draft of hb2
does not modify that I I think I'd need
to take a closer look at the statute to
determine whether that would need to be
or not but yeah
all right so I believe we're up to slide
15 is that
correct oh okay 14 sure 14 14 yep um and
this was just a followup on the uh
Resource Center um they have done
surveys and um they've assessed
particular programs and and part of that
is this is just to let you know that we
are measuring and looking at the um
involvement of the Community Based
Services and what impact it has on
children and their families and um their
positive outcomes and so you can see
those
there we do have the statistics that
we'll go into starting on slide
15 so early childhood wraparound we
talked about fast forward before this is
the same exact concept but it targets uh
children who are birth to five and I
remember when we first started this
program everyone's like someone at Birth
how could you identify that they have a
mental health um condition and really
this is about that early detection and
early family supports and having um the
support so it's really looking at the
caregivers um and how um those
wraparound Services can help the whole
family um through this process so this
is a Medicaid um funded service so we
received uh approval to be able to cover
these Services um and this you can see
the growth over time what I'm going to
be showing you are statistics that show
slow steady progress and I think that's
really important because when we think
about fundamental changes to our system
um the idea of just flooding a system um
saying shutting down residential
programs and having them all go
community- based would not be able to be
done on a dime it needs to be
incremental um as we go through and do
it in a very measured and capacity
building um and the utilization in this
steady way so this steady growth is
great from my perspective because we're
able to have the um proof of concept go
from 8 in you know in July of 22 um to
the the 63 um that we have um in January
and so um again I think it's a good sign
that we're um adding and continuing to
grow but not so rapidly that we're
overwhelming any particular community
provider or any um
service representative Neno for a
question yeah very quick question come
back to the ages birth def F so I I
assume that and if I'm incorrect that
that would apply to um mothers that that
are uh substance addicted and and and
then the question is how much of that do
you see and how how do you get those
referrals yeah so that's a great
question so yes that's a a very good um
description of um the situations that um
people are facing we have many um pcps
who will identify that so primary care
physicians um we have um hospitals that
are working with a family or come across
a family um we have you know it could be
a sibling situation um with a family
that's known to a community it could be
schools so there are many referral
sources for these programs and just a
quick followup are so with all of the
you know uh evidence of uh problems with
all kinds of drugs in New Hampshire are
we seeing an increase in those kinds of
referrals or and you know any um kind of
numbers that you uh might put on that
yeah so um referrals you're seeing
actually numbers served we I'm not sure
if we included it here but we also do
numbers of referrals um so that you can
see over time um the demand um for those
services and for the increased knowledge
again we do those trainings and we do
that Outreach um specifically to our
field staff for DCF and um for Juvenile
Justice and others um but I don't have
those numbers here for the
referrals um but that is a good point
and that's um it's really important that
people once they have been identified
and they identify themselves as having a
need that we able to meet their um meet
that need so if you could provide at
least some rough numbers on uh that
particular portion of the referrals
would be interested to uh see that
absolutely and that's something that we
uh share with children's oversight um on
a monthly basis um and and can certainly
share it
here thank you
um and so page 16 is fast forward so
this is the population that um we talked
about earlier which is 5 to 21 and again
you can see that growth this program um
has been I'm sorry slide 16 15 oh 15
okay all right my my numbers are off and
that's why he had said do you want the
actual color copy so um so when I
printed it it I'm off so I'm sorry for
that um but this one's talking about
fast forward so we're on slide
15 um again growth of the system um the
we've seen the growth in the referrals
and then the
enrollments this is delivered by our uh
Care Management entities and we have two
of them so that's why you see the two
different um line graphs um in the bars
representative Stringham for a question
uh I just not notice you know you have
different you know number sered since
2015 other one was 23 does that
represent the start date of those
particular Services absolutely yes yeah
and so that's why you can see um fast
forward came well before the Early
Childhood wraparound which we recently
added um based on the success of fast
forward
representative priest for a question
thank you Madame chairman uh Miss Fox do
you have the referrals uh to the fast
forward
enrollments we do I you uh provide that
to us yes thank
you okay yes all set thank you okay so
um the next slide I believe is 16 I'll
get back on track with this is
Transitional enhanced care coordination
so this is
specif okay now I'm back on
track all right everyone I think it
knows where I am so the TR program um is
how we refer to it and this is specific
for Youth and families um for the Youth
who are transitioning in or out of a
residential treatment program or a
psychiatric hospitalization say at
Hamstead for example and this is the
ability for that oversight and the
coordination of care through that
transition process many of the services
that I'm talking about and I'll be
talking about um later as well is that
those transitions are one of the most
important points of contact and uh level
of service that are um make a difference
because that's where we lose people so
to speak where um we um have a gap and
then um they get disconnected from
services so this program oversees the um
those Transitions and helps in uh making
sure that as those transitions happen
that all of the services are in place um
upon uh discharge from a residential or
a psychiatric um acute
setting representative Daniels for a
question yes as we look at this chart
how are we supposed to know how many uh
transitioning in or
out in or out that I don't think you can
figure it out from this so we will We I
can get that for you of how many um I
think what see is that they will follow
someone pre um entry into residential
treatment if they're identified um early
enough and then post as well um for
example if there is a youth at this new
news center um we know that they're
going to be there and so those Services
prior to um will be touching base and
understanding um the family Dynamics and
the use situation
and that there are some touch points
when someone was is within that um
setting and then when they come out they
pick them up so that it's not just like
okay you're there they maintain that
contact UM throughout that episode so I
think there going to be situations where
that happens and then there'll be other
situations where the first time we come
into contact with a family is when um
their youth or or child ends up in a
acute setting so I think you'll have a
mix of both and I'll see if we can purse
that out for you okay and and I guess ju
just for your information what what I'm
trying to look for is the success rate
yeah I mean you we've heard that uh
being being able to move them out of
residential into the community is more
of a success but as I look at the charts
it looks like the numbers are
continually growing and you've presented
that as a positive thing but you know
I'm sitting here saying you know are we
seeing any successes you know I I would
think that if we were doing things right
that maybe we would see the numbers
start to go
down I agree and again it's really hard
to when we look at the data to uh
determine what we consider success
versus um what is not successful and
that can be because um we've reached out
to more families and there are more
families who are now Ware of our
services um or is it because um there's
a you know there's a problem so totally
under I totally get it yeah thank
you representative Nano followed by
representative priest thank you madam
chair thank you Miss Fox for taking the
question uh we earlier touched on
briefly on the question of um suicide
and suicide prevention and so I'm just
wondering does uh uh does your division
track uh suicides in the context of
cases that you're you're dealing with uh
over
time so there is a suicide prevention
Council that is established um by by
Statute and they issue an annual report
um that has data um and it has the age
breakdown ages broken down and that
information comes from our chief um
examiner's office our medical examiner's
office and that's data that's pulled
together and so if you'd like a copy of
that report I can make sure you get it
yeah I was just interested whether we're
seeing a you know a lot of it a little
of it or and what the
trends uh look like yeah okay we can get
that for
you representative
priest uh thank you Madame chairman and
thank you Miss Fox for uh taking my
question um I I would like to applaud
you and your department for reach for
getting more and more people who have
needs to come and seek and get treatment
for that how many referrals do you have
and how many people do you have to turn
away because you do not have the
residential facilities to handle them so
we're going to get a little bit more
into the residential settings in a
couple slides um and you'll see that
how many referrals how many referrals do
you have uh for this particular program
so uh it's interesting because when you
say referral it's not just okay a
referral it's a screening assessment uh
determination of a level of care so
there may be um someone who needs a
residential specific level or a
specialty service right so um so I'm not
quite sure
you've answered yeah you've clarified my
question thank you very much
okay all right page
18 this is exactly where we're going
next we're talking about Residential
Treatment this is a report that we um
issue monthly or we can do it point in
time and this gives you a sense of where
um our youth are and our children are in
residential treatment um at at any point
so we have um the programs that are in
New Hampshire that you're familiar with
um so there's Nation children's home um
do uh Spalding Easter Seals you start to
hear these names and you can think about
them as you think about your communities
and what services you have in your
communities so we have the New Hampshire
programs and you'll see the numbers
there of how many uh Children and Youth
are in those uh facilities we have those
in New England and um primarily in
Vermont Massachusetts and
Maine and then we have National programs
which we've heard a lot about um so we
have um as of the point in time when
this data was pulled in early February
339 uh children who are in residential
hair and then I can give you a minute
just to look at um some of the data
rather than reading it to you but you
can look at the age breakdown the case
type which you can tie back to um the
DCF presentation yesterday and then the
levels of care um which go all the way
up to the um prtf which in New Hampshire
we have um a prtf at ham Hospital
representative tarki for a question just
a quick question about the um the
different case situations knowing that
our hope is to have our kids home um can
you just talk about what kind of needs
those eight children have that are so
significantly far away like what are
some of these situations that require
this um the one that comes to mind um
most um quickly is the um situation
where you may have someone who has a
medical need um so they're medically
fragile they may have some type of
condition that isn't necessarily
controlled as well as the mental health
condition um so they have multiple needs
it's hard when we have a specialty case
to have a program a full program that
has um the ability to stand up when you
have one particular particular case so
if you think of some of the cases of um
and I really shouldn't Callum cases
their families their kids um their there
are um neighbors um they have such
complex needs where they may have um an
intellectual disorder a mental health
condition um a physical um need some
type of
disability and there just isn't any
specialized program for that to address
that they may have it disorder is
another one that um we think of um so
those are really the um outliers those
cases and it's really important that we
have a place for them to get the
treatment that they need and that's why
we do have to rely on those National
programs so does New Hampshire have
equality program for eating disorders or
do they have to go somewhere else in New
England that that's typically out of
state that's too bad okay thank
you with regard to the age ranges there
on page
18 uh do you know if those numbers are
average in terms of numbers in those age
categories are they above average below
any idea where we
stand um so from a national perspective
is that your question I'm thinking more
in state
but it's okay if you don't I was just
curious um especially in terms of the 0o
to four range and the 5 to 11 if those
were above average
or yeah I I would need to get back to
you on that as you see most of the
population falls into that uh Teenage
population right 12 to 17 okay no
problem thank you okay representative
seaworth followed by representative PR
thank you very much um so you mentioned
the connection with this this
presentation with what we heard
yesterday and I certainly remember some
of the numbers line up if I'm now
thinking about the budget and let's say
I I'm looking at the cost for the eight
out of state is this going to be spread
among um different budgets how do I
connect funding to the kids rather than
the the
Departments you want to be able to track
cost by
child and and not
in that makes it sound like I want to do
more than I really want to do just when
I'm trying to get my mind around the
total cost of this thing how do I know
that I'm looking at all the different
places that funds it so it maybe just a
high level of how the funding crosses
between departments for a single purpose
sure and and and that's that analysis or
that that compilation that we're working
on and again um to to katu's point it
it's based on the specific needs of the
child and what the child is eligible for
so if if it's if if they're eligible for
Medicaid then the service portion could
be paid for with Medicaid but the ren
board if they're not eligible for tanif
or fore then that may be 100% General
funds but if they're eligible for tanif
then the ren board and education are
paid with tanif and potentially and then
but but then the services may be paid
for with tanip instead of Medicaid and
so I I I have a I have a matrix that
that the team's put together over the
years to try to Simply explain that and
I think that's one of the challenges
with um with the way that that we're
currently looking at this and and we've
already started to have internal
conversations around like going forward
in future years is there an easier way
that we can budget this to give the
legislature better insight and ourselves
better Insight in order to be able to
track this consistently so you know
right now I'm anticipating a change for
the next bium because we want to be
transparent and be able to demonstrate
this and that's that that's that
document that we'll have for you next
week so I can try to get to your
question a little bit more directly okay
thank you very much that's exactly what
I'm I'm
thinking thank you madam chairman back
to page um 15 is this for Fisco year 24
or uh the numbers that you have provided
us I want to make sure I'm on
right yeah this is for State fiscal year
23 is what we have here 23 do you oh
since 23 I'm sorry since 23 yep so if
you looked it goes from July of 22 all
the way through to January of 25 okay so
it starts out in uh 14 so that's since
the birth of the program so of great um
thank you very much representative nello
for a question yeah it's just a
follow-up question to representative
seaworth question so his question was
fundamentally an
accounting uh uh question but um the
other side of this is I'd be interested
to know out of the eight what the range
you know what the range of cost was
lowest to highest for that group of
eight and that would that would
obviously you know have some correlation
to how the accounting uh shakes out on
that you know without any identifying
individuals or anything but just looking
at lowest to highest and median
uh recognizing that each one of these
cases is unique sure that that would
probably be a large amount of manual
work because each each child is going to
have different needs they're going to be
Serv they're going to be potentially at
different placement locations that have
different rates and then you're going to
have a different mix of funding and the
start and the end dates are all going to
be different so one case may be for 3
months one may be for 9 months one may
be for some other period of time so it
it it it's a it would likely be a fairly
in-depth analysis because as as Marie
nun and the DCF director was saying
yesterday we the the bridges system that
we use to track some of these expenses
for these children it came out in 1997
and so as I've been saying internally
that's the like the hate of AOL I mean
it's a very Antiquated system and we're
working on revising that so we're not
able to pull reports in real time um
quickly to be able to get to that level
of detail it could be done manually with
with quite a bit of work well I I'm kind
of surprised with that because you have
a case number assigned to each
individual and costs associated with
that case I would assume so this is a
very high level thing and and if you're
tracking it that way all you're looking
for is a
gross um uh kind of a range so I'm I'm
not sure I understand why I'm not
looking for a lot of detail I'm looking
really for high
uh numbers like like a sample of 10 well
there a sample of eight here I guess in
this particular case okay sure yeah
thank
you all right um so page
19 so um this is the assessment that I
referenced earlier and as part of the
road map for the Department we
identified the need to look at the
system of care it has been um eight
years or so that it's been established
and it was time to take another look and
see how are we doing how are we um
providing those services are we meeting
the needs what are the gaps and um how
do we go about better coordinating the
system of care um and so we have been
working um to do that we have
stakeholder input and we will um be
getting a an issuing a final report um
in the next month or so and so we look
forward to that and appreciate everybody
who has uh contributed to that
effort okay that um is the system of
care and the children's uh Bureau
um I'm going to move now and the reason
why that this comes next is because uh
the children's system is served by this
service um by rapid response and
integrated services and so you're not
seeing a new Bureau show up here because
again it's part of the um division-wide
approach to uh crisis services for all
populations representative Stringham for
a question yeah just make sure I
understand all those different Services
the five level residential treatments in
state out of state out of New
England uh all those things are
contained in those two departments uh
that we first went through and managed
by nine people three which positions are
currently uh unfunded and unfilled is
that
correct yes um however um we do have um
the dcy F which is overseeing the cases
so um the ones that the uh Youth and
children are involved in we have DCF as
a co-partner so they're doing visits
with families and they're doing all the
work that they do in the community so um
I don't want to say that you know six
people are doing all of this work I will
say for the residential program we have
three staff that are dedicated to that
and then as Nathan mentioned earlier um
the
um HB
1573 increased the um oversight for
residential programs and we had hoped to
have two positions created as part of
that um and as a um way to in the
interim is that we're um providing
overtime so that we can increase the
amount of visits that we have from a
quality uh perspective for those
residential
settings representative tki for a
question thanks um yesterday afternoon
when we were having a conversation with
DCF I don't believe you were here but
there was a question from represent
Neno about um how do
we reduce the numbers of kids who are
affected and the answer sort of boiled
down to re family resources and syst
system of care um do you want to speak
on that with this program as prevention
and getting ahead of situations before
they end up in the system absolutely our
division serves the community that were
all community- Based Services um the
idea of any Reliance on any inpatient or
residential program we want to reduce it
as much as we can we know that um what
works you've seen some of our statistics
there are other programs that are making
a big difference for families um and we
want to continue those efforts double
those efforts uh we want to focus on
what works and that's why we're doing
the assessment to determine what other
uh gaps we can fill at the community
level and um there will always be a
population that needs acute services
that needs Residential Services we can't
just make it go away and think that the
community can absorb um the the need um
and we need further training we need
further uh tools to be able to help
families um address the the needs of
their um loved
ones okay so rapid response
um again we've talked about this quite a
bit I think um from the last bium into
this bium and the program continues to
mature um it is you know we call it um
New Hampshire rapid response we have an
access point which is the phone number
that you call and then we have mobile
crisis units a lot of people think this
is just as mobile crisis but they're all
part of that uh program that is to
address um when someone's in an acute
crisis and so we have that access point
that is the
247 call you can text and um do a chat
um there are initial assessments uh you
quickly get on the phone and find out
what the need is sometimes it's
information and referral other times
it's an acute crisis that does not need
911 response um but is for that person
on the phone right then an
emergency um so the access point
coordinates when a response is needed so
they make the determination whether or
not there needs to be a mobile
deployment into the community um and so
that assessment is made um and then the
if needed um mobile crisis is deployed
the 10 Community Mental Health Centers
deliver the mobile crisis Services it's
a Statewide approach so that um you may
have for example in Manchester you may
have more than one need for a mobile
deployment um at once so at the same
time so you would have your nearest
mental health center deploy their mobile
unit um to address that second so um
while we have regions we have a
Statewide approach to um the mobile
crisis response repres pres Nano for a
question yes thank you madam chair thank
you Miss Fox um I'm wondering if uh I I
trying to understand the little asterisk
on the bottom of page 20 that says the
crisis model is funded through state
general funds but then it goes on to say
is a requirement of the federal
Community Mental Health block grant yeah
so so yeah it's a little um confusing I
saw that this morning when I was
reviewing and I'm glad asset so I can
clarify um so it's required that we take
our block grant dollars that we receive
from samsa for our mental health block
grant and we have a set aside so they
require they you know give us I forget
how much million it's in here um dollars
but then they say of that amount 5% must
be spent on crisis
response so this is our spending um
meeting that requirement so we do have
General funds we have the requirement um
of the block grant that we spend that 5%
set aside and and we've referred to that
as as maintenance of effort requirement
previously when we've talked about that
where we have to expend x amount of
General funds in order to continue to
receive the federal block
grant okay so so then
roughly how much of the you know how
much of this is funded Federal money and
how much of it is is general fund money
and how can I you know yeah we have that
um and it's in our contract um it has
the spread of where that comes from so
we'll be able to get that for you um
it's it's
primarily General funds when it comes to
the access point when it comes to the
mobile crisis response the deployment of
the unit um that is more likely to be
Medicaid
billable okay thank you
okay and then the third pillar for the
um integrated crisis response is
somewhere to go and this was um a gap
and a need that we identified pretty
quickly it's great that you can have a
mobile deployment but there are
situations in which someone you respond
to may not have anywhere to go from
there and so the idea is to have a
crisis center where someone can go for
23 and a half hours um otherwise you
fall into licensing requirements um but
the idea is that you stabilize someone
there where they um are able to speak
with peers they're able to um have
someone help them navigate through the
next
step representative priest for a
question thank you madam chairman and
thank you Miss Fox um if are all of the
Regional Crisis centers equal in the
services that they provide and say if
someone from the North country has a a
crisis that they cannot handle do they
then uh transfer him to like Manchester
or NASA where the service would be
provided so that's um a very good
question our 10 Community Mental Health
Centers have certain core services that
they all are standardized and are
embedded Within our administrative rules
um when it comes to um the challenges
that are faced especially in the rural
parts of our state mobile crisis would
be one really good example um we have um
had a differential response where we're
able to have um Northern Human Services
covers those counties um that um are
more remote and have much more travel
time and they also have five offices and
they have so when we think of mobile
crisis you think of a unit and
everybody's together and they're all
together 24/7 in a van that's not how it
works they're on call and they're
deployed and so they've strategically
worked through that but it continues to
be a
challenge all
right um and so I just um following up
on the regional crisis centers so we
have two that have been stood up
um the most recent was um in Plymouth uh
by Lakes Region mental health and Center
For Life Management in Dairy um was the
early adopter and um they they are
available um and these are not the full
model they're not 247 right now and
they're not the Staffing model model
that you would see um at the National
Best Practices but they are available
and they are staffed um and so they were
able to
open
okay page
21 Madam
chair representative Neno for a question
yeah a a very quick question on the one
it says mobile dispatch and this is a
crisis is that that's a private indivi I
mean one of your care providers in their
own vehicle or does it an you know is it
interfac with law enforcement uh and how
how is this system uh what does it look
like in in practice Yeah so um yes yes
and yes and what it looks like in
practice is individualized so it could
be that law enforcement responds and
determines that someone does not need to
have law enforcement involvement and so
they will call and a um a team will be
dispatched
um the again the idea that it's a
vehicle and a van driving around that's
not how it works it's usually people on
call and then they respond from their
homes or out of um out of their offices
if it's during the daytime um and so it
could be I know early on um it was
really interesting because schools would
call and they would have um a youth who
was having a a mental health crisis and
maybe Mom was working um and unable to
get to the school so mobile crisis was
able to go and help um help that student
um get through and they never had to go
anywhere else they didn't have to hit an
emergency room so they're all very
different in different situations um
some could be law enforcement involved
some could be school involved and some
could just be a family um struggling and
and needing some help and we have
protocol and um have worked out details
when um with 911 so we understand if a
call goes to
911 um what would be needed for a
response versus a call going through um
988 or through the crisis
line thank
you representative priest for a question
thank you madam chairman on this uh on
page
21 um you uh this information is from
from July
22nd to December 24th and it's very
impressive of how many people you first
get contacts with and the assessments
that you do and then there's then the
additional services that you Pro provide
to those who need them um do you have
anything that shows or Compares this
information to other areas in Northern
New
England no
yeah I I haven't seen it if it exists so
if there are other states that have a
similar system and comparing our stats
to theirs I haven't seen that and again
this has just been created since January
22nd is that correct yes okay thank you
yeah all
right slide
22 so again this is just a further
breakdown
we went all out on rapid response
because we had data and we wanted to
show you
data um and so this is the breakdown for
um individuals to be who are um 0 to
17 I'll bring my water up and when we
take a break um so you can see the um
contacts the unique numbers served um so
you can see sometimes there are multiple
uh contacts with the same person and
family which we don't want to discourage
we think that's a good thing and then
how many um dispatches have been
requested representative walner has a
question so as I look at the three
charts it looks like about half of
the contacts that come in to the um
original telephone call I guess um end
up being referred over so what kind of
skills who who who is answering that
phone and obviously being able to help
divert
people yeah so we have a contract for
that um we have a call center um carolon
is our current
contractor um and they are trained up on
crisis
response um and um have you know backup
as needed um and can tap expertise
within their own organization as needed
um and the um deployments really we are
going to air on the side of caution if
someone says they want someone we're
going to
respond does that answer your question
fully yeah I just wondered you know what
sort of skills the uh people at the
other end of the phone had yeah they are
they're quite skilled in being able to
do this screening and initial assessment
and um we do um spot checks to make sure
um that the staff are trained up thank
you representative seaworth for a
question thank you very much I just want
to make sure I understand what I'm
looking at um the drop off from chart
one to chart two part of that might
be screening out the request on the
phone some of that as you said is that
the same individual or same family needs
to contact multiple time so it's one
person served but maybe five
contacts is it mostly one or the other
or is it just a combination of
everything I believe it's a combination
um I I would need to double check on
that okay so um so 22 and 23 are very
similar um the uh 23 is 18 and older um
and I believe if you look at this you'll
see that the number of dispatches um for
uh mobile response to the community are
higher for children and again looking at
um that airing on the side of caution
and the request um we try not to say you
don't need us we never say you don't
need us us if there is a a call for this
then we're going to
respond um many of the calls too are
resolved um through this contact and
initial assessment um through either um
having the opportunity to talk through a
situation and through you know a
referral um and may not be deemed what
you or I might call crisis but for that
person at that moment um is a need
that's being met
and because we haven't hammered at home
yet enough we'll go to page
24 and um this really looks at the 988
system and the number of um calls that
have um been made and really talking
about um the
avoidance of having to go to an
emergency department which has been
really really the the whole point of
this whole system is to avoid having
families having to end up in an
emergency room for a mental health
crisis representative Neno for a
question yes thank you madam chair this
this comes back I think the question I
asked earlier so there there are
988 uh uh
I guess suicide and crisis but no the
breakdown of that is you know um the
question I asked before was how many
suicides and whether we attract them so
the suicide in crisis is you know
there's no distinction you don't have
any thing that breaks down how many of
these are suicide and how many are you
treating them all as as potential
suicide so I don't know as though that's
a stat that we keep whether it's a
mental health crisis or it's identified
specifically as I'm feeling
suicidal um so I would have to check on
that um but again this is really just to
be in a preventative way to have a place
for someone to call should they need and
be in a mental health crisis including
um if they are feeling like they're
going to harm themselves um but the
actual statistics about um suicides are
kept separately and and not through this
system just a quick followup the reason
I'm asking the question is one of the
metrics if if you've got a suicide
prevention program is you know what what
what's the number of suicides over time
and and is that going down or is that
increasing as a measure of the success
of preventing suicides absolutely and
and I want to get that report to you
okay thank you
okay so we are now going to the Bureau
of Mental Health Services which is the
adult
population so if we look at slide 26 and
we have representative priest for a
question yes thank you madam chairman
and Miss Fox again just for a
clarification back on page
24 is this the total number that we're
looking at that of of all the AG groups
yes okay thank you
from from December of 21 to the to
January 25
right yes okay thank you December 24 yep
December of 24 so
yeah all right
so back to the
budget which I think is what we're here
for today um so we have the Bureau of
Mental Health Services um it has um the
accounting units as you can see here um
the first one the pro health New
Hampshire grant that Grant has ended um
so while you see it um in 24 and 25 it
does not carry forth because the grant
has ended
the Office of Consumer and family
Affairs that's 100% General funds and
out of that we fund um I'm just going to
make sure and I'm sure somebody behind
me will jump up if I'm incorrect but we
do um fund the staff that oversee our
peer support
agencies and then uh for Guardianship
Services that is um we have contracts
for Guardianship Services that um there
are with two um agencies and I think
we'll talk about that when we talk about
prioritized
needs same with commitment costs um
these are attorneys who represent
individuals who have been subjected to
an involuntary emergency admission um
and so we have contracts with attorneys
in that accounting
unit and then interim care funds are
very very small amount of funds that are
used in um unique circumstances where
someone may need just one little bit of
um pot of money um to be able to
maintain tenure in the community
as we continue on slide 27 this is where
we start getting into the bulk and the
meat of the um of the contracts and the
funding and the services so we have the
community mental health program
support you'll see a lot of that is
General funds and when we talked about
mobile crisis that's where that is
funded
we have the next one which is peer
support services which are the peer
support agencies that are across the
state we have contracts I believe with
eight
organizations and there um are 10
locations I believe throughout the state
these are an a regional approach just
like we have our community mental health
uh services
Family mutual supports is a contract
with nami New Hampshire and they provide
uh groups throughout the state and um
support families um as they address
their loved ones mental health
needs the mental health block grant is
the federally um funded block grant for
mental health from
SSA and this has funding that is goes
towards our um peer support agencies so
they have a mix of funds Our Community
Mental Health
Centers and um our crisis when we talked
about the set aside that's needed the 5%
um that is for the access point um with
the Caroline contract that I
mentioned the next account um Mental
Health Data collect ction we um disperse
those funds to our community mental
health centers and we have a contract
for our consumer satisfaction uh survey
that's done um with a contract as
well and I will stop there because I'm
sure there are questions on these
accounts representative priest for a
question thank you madam chairman and
thank you Miss Fox for taking my
question um back
to back to page
26 on the commitment CA you mentioned
that you have contracts with attorneys
as the KNE based where is that shown on
page
10,5 sure so in accounting unit 4115
you'll see that in class line one 8
provider payments legal services and um
for the compared to the current um
budget we have essentially flatlined
that at the same amount and
rate okay I see it okay thank
you thank
you representative walner followed by
representative
tersi thank you so on page um 1
six I do notice that under the contract
for the mental health
centers uh there is a considerable
increase and I know when you were when
you presented uh to us maybe a week or
two ago you mentioned that you were
concerned about the mental health
centers um some of them being
fiscally
in having problems and I wondered um um
does this increase will this increase
help Shore them up and be sure that they
can continue their
work sure so I I I I would like to point
out that the um what you will see within
the class 102 in accounting unit 4117 on
page 106 of the governor's operating
budget the $5
million um that the department had
requested in the prioritized need need
each year was indeed funded I can like K
you speak to that that specific
prioritized need yeah um and we did talk
about that and I believe that you've
heard from the Behavioral Health
Association about that as well about
uncompensated care um as we've increased
Services um and um have access um to
these Services the Community Mental
Health Centers not only have they um
experience with the Medicaid unwind
which is I think you heard about from
director Litman um that people who um
had qualified for Medicaid during the
pandemic stayed on Medicaid and then um
were no longer eligible for Medicaid or
for some other reason um were no longer
covered by Medicaid and so the Community
Mental Health Centers continued to
provide those services to those
individuals and so they had no
compensation um for that um as much as
self-pay um as they could get they would
get um the other thing is there are
services that are paid for by Medicaid
that are not paid for um by commercial
insurers so somebody who is commercially
insured may not have the ability to get
something covered um because it's just
not a covered service so functional
Support Services is one of those
services so the Community Mental Health
Centers um continue to provide services
that they're not compensated for and we
have seen a growth in that and um an
increase in their operating losses and
we had asked for a continuation of a
one-time infusion of funds um in the uh
La in this current biennium and so we
had asked to continue that uh $5 million
in each fiscal year and it was funded um
and recognized by the governor as a need
to um continue um the Community Mental
Health Center's work um I'll leave it at
that I think there representative tersi
followed by representative
Stringham representative tersi yields
representative
Stringham yeah so you know we notic that
um the um you know page 10 7 that uh the
budget was 24 million or actual
expenditures was is the reason why
that's somewhat lower is because there's
um non-aps funds from the previous bium
or have we really are we really talking
about a doubling of this um uh area sure
and and I I I think this is one of the
challenges with with the when you're
looking at the governor's operating
budget because you're not looking at
what was budgeted um it's a great
question so what was budgeted in the
current uh State fiscal year was about
$41.5
million um that particular class line
does have a class note that allows for
the appropriation to carry forward what
we experienced in uh in the initial year
was uh some some billing delays so those
expenses will still occur but they'll be
they'll occur in state fiscal year 25
for some of the 24 uh Services is what
we're anticipating right now so the um o
overall the largest increase that that
you're seeing there is that that
additional $5
million um that was added it is 100%
General funds um and there is no
available Federal match for
that yeah so this this area overall
we're looking at you know
99% uh General funds so yes that is
correct there there's only a small
amount of Medicaid admin that we're able
to claim in this area but is primarily
General funds thank
you all right let me get back on track
here so I think we're on page
28 which is really just an overview of
the service system so again going from
all the way from Community Education and
awareness up to inpatient services with
a lot in between um so um we have the
strongest Granite campaign that's the
one I referenced earlier um that was a
universal approach to all populations
letting them know that help is available
and there is strength in help seeking um
and that campaign was pretty successful
I have the stats on that but I don't
think I have them with me about you know
the Impressions the advertising the
responses you know visits to sites uh to
the site and things like that but um
very very um successful
campaign we have uh first episode
psychosis which is um a way to be able
to identify after that first episode and
get early intervention services to um a
person and their
family peer support we've talked about
we okay there are 12 locations I said 10
earlier corrected by myself um so it's
and we have peer respit programs so when
we look at the housing Continuum and the
needs um of individuals they have small
programs for beds a piece um and they
are able to stay have short stays
they're usually about a week to couple
weeks um and it's for peers for peers
and so um this is added to our ability
to address the needs of individual who
need just that break um as they take um
from their community and take their next
steps Community Based Services and
supports again the um bedrock and um the
foundation are our community mental
health centers they provide a full array
of
services um including those that are
listed here we have um two centers as
we talked about there are Federal grant
opportunities and there was the
certified community behavioral health
clinics um and so we've worked very
closely with three Mental Health Centers
two of which have since become these
clinics they're
essentially
um enhanced community base uh Community
Mental Health Centers so they have their
Community Mental Health Centers plus and
that plus is um the integrated approach
with substance use services and the um
close connection with physical Medical
Services I see questions so at least on
the tip of the people's tongues
perhaps bu I think we're all set okay
great so um two have been certified they
um started um with their new payment
methodology and being the full-blown
ccbhcs and that's um in Manchester and
NASA and West Central in Lebanon will be
coming on board um by
July the uh next is residential
treatment and housing supports um we
have a slide in here that shows the
growth of um the um type of um housing
supports that we have we have again the
crisis Services we talked about and then
we have inpatient Services which you'll
hear more about um when um you have New
Hampshire hospital appear before you in
talking about the designated receiving
facility beds of which there are 65 in
locations other than New Hampshire
hospital um the most recent of which is
Dartmouth Health has added five um five
beds and I think we're on page 29 and we
start looking at some statistics
again the reason why we picked these
numbers to go through June of 2024 is
because we had two Community Mental
Health Centers that converted um to
their emrs to new uh software and new
programs so they were not able to they
haven't been able to produce the numbers
and anyone who sits on fiscal committee
and sees the monthly dashboard knows
that there has been a drop and that's a
result to those two centers unable to be
able to produce those um numbers they're
on it they're um looking at April an
April time frame to be able to start
populating from a financial standpoint
and the data um that's needed and and
how we capture it representative priest
for a
question thank you Madame chairman uh
back to um there's always a delay
process with me and I'm sorry about that
but on page 28
on the inpatient uh
Services what is the vacancy rate for
those
beds that is a great question and we're
going to get a little bit into um what
the state has done so that there isn't a
huge vacancy rate um I don't know the
actual percentage but I would say that
it's
probably on most days less than 10% okay
thank you
so on uh slide 29 again showing and it's
breaking it down between adults and
children and this really is looking at
eligible children so they're and adults
and when we talk about eligibility it's
a criteria that's established in um law
and Rule which um talks about um severe
mental illness and what the criteria is
for that and so that's what makes one
eligible so this doesn't address all um
individuals who are seeking um services
for mental health it just is for those
it's depicting those who are
eligible all right um so page 30 I think
we're doing well on time here so um we
have more than 98% of adults served by
the committee Mental Health Centers get
their treatment in an outpatient
Community Based setting so again um
that's always our goal we don't want
people to have to hit a real high level
of care um if it's needed we want it to
be available for those acute circum and
unique circumstances but we find we know
that uh treatment in the community uh
works and it it's available and um
that's where the need is and where we're
meeting that
need all right slide
31 so critical time intervention is a
program that was supported um by the
legislature um and it looks and so you
can see the timeline of when it started
and where it is today
um this looks at again transitions this
is going back to what I said earlier
about how those transitions in care are
so important and so it's why it's named
critical time um that it's a a point in
time when someone who's leaving an acute
setting and going into the community
gets the care coordination and the help
they need and this is not um a clinical
service it's really a a um a service
that looks at real basic needs and
helping an individual navigate those
needs and finding housing and finding
the food bank and um work and and
working with um individuals the reason
why you see those numbers go up and down
so wildly first of all the numbers are
pretty small
um oh I'm sorry I was looking I was
thinking of CTI CTI is an area where
we've had some staffing challenges the
Community Mental Health Centers have had
Staffing challenges so if I were to
present the data here which is not here
um you would see some ups and downs as
um the Staffing CH has changed over time
um but this is really about their
readmissions and this is um a a big um
data point that we look at we look at 30
60 990 and 180 day readmission
and um this is something that we um work
with our Managed Care organizations we
look at for the critical time
Intervention Program um and it's
something that we hold ourselves
accountable to because once someone is
discharged we want them to be able to
stay in the community and how are we
doing and how are we helping them do
that representative priest for a
question thank you madam chairman thank
you Mrs fo Miss Fox for uh taking my
question um I'm
I'm I'm very happy to see that you are
addressing the need for a recovery of
your patients and making sure and to
reduce their
re-emissions are you coordinating your
programs with
communities and private recovery houses
um that we are seeing now in all of our
communities so um coordination of
services is so important and um when we
say that it's not just to a community
mental health center but it may be other
um types of services in a community um
when we talk about recovery housing I
think it it's tough because we you know
immediately like oh no we're going to
talk about that with our Bureau of drug
and alcohol services and we're going to
talk about that but there is um
Supportive Housing in the mental health
field as well and so um we do have a
process and we do have some oversight
over uh recovery housing which we'll
talk about in a
minute
okay so this is the housing inventory um
we're pretty proud of this because we
have been able to add to the inventory
of Supportive Housing um despite the
housing uh Crunch and so we've been
doing that in um several different ways
of how we've been able to do that um
which I can talk about but this just
shows that growth in how many people
were able to support um in housing units
across the
state Miss Fox we're approaching the
noon time hour and so I'm just curious
as to your thoughts of a Breaking Point
um and your thoughts for it looks like
we're about halfway through the
presentation so I'm anticipating
probably another at least two hours more
of presenting unless you think
differently but your thoughts um so I
really want to talk a lot about Mission
zero because I know it's something that
you've heard about and so I worry that
if we start that now then um we it might
be 1:00 before we finish um so it could
be a good breaking point but um we're
here for you and plan the day on it so
sounds good is everybody okay to break
now for one
hour one hour okay we will reconvene we
will pause thank you both very much oh
representative Stringham I was going to
say if we can make it shorter that would
be helpful for me but I'm okay with an
hour if everybody needs an hour okay a
half an hour um does that work for the
committee
can we compromise on 45 minutes is that
all right 45 minutes very good so we
will reconvene at
1245 thank you very
much
e
e e
good afternoon all we'll reconvene this
division three of house finance
committee work session on Thursday
February 27th
20125 the topic is the division of
Behavioral Health we've gone the whole
morning
since 10:00 a.m. through a packet that
can be found online and now we'll
continue uh where we were I think on
page
33 and we'll go from there I do intend
to ask members of the audience if
they're interested in testifying after
the presentation concludes whenever
whatever time that may be okay ready to
begin when you're ready great thank you
and good
afternoon so as we were talking about um
we want to get a little bit into Mission
zero which again I think is something
that um people have heard about what is
Mission zero our um goal to have no one
waiting in an emergency department in
the state of New Hampshire for an
inpatient uh bed for mental health
services
and
so I tried to hydrate uh over lunch so
we'll see if I can do a little better
with my voice here um so for this
particular graphic you'll see that as
part of mission zero we had six key
Investments that we identified as
needing to help us achieve that mission
and so the certified community
behavioral health clinics which I
already talked about a little bit ago
the um crisis uh stabilization centers
we talked about those as well care
traffic control that is something that
you'll hear about more from New
Hampshire hospital um and that really
goes to what we are talking about the
utilization of designated receiving
facility beds they are now able to know
in real time what beds are occupied and
what which are available um should
someone present an emergency department
in the state and be able to help
coordinate that effort so that a person
can get into that um service level of
service um in real time um so that's
been really beneficial and helped us
with that utilization so that uh we are
closer to full utilization and not
having um beds go unus when somebody
could um needs one we've had an
expansion in the designated receiving
facility beds I mentioned the Dartmouth
uh beds that have opened up and as part
of the
HCA um acquisition of Catholic Medical
Center there are going to be 10
additional beds that were part of that
um requirement through the Attorney
General's approval of that acquisition
um and so those will be additional drf
beds that will be coming
online we've had expansions in the care
in step down and less restrictive
settings this is really addressing one
of the drivers which um as you can see
on the right hand side we have the front
door the demand we have the impatient
Supply the number of beds that are
available and then we have the back door
where does someone go once they um no
longer need that acute level uh service
and so those um supported housing that
we've already talked about um and shown
the growth of the um availability of
supported housing um this is what number
five is
addressing and then number six is a
program that has been very successful it
is landlord incentives and this allows
someone to have um a place that's
available it's coupled with a bridge
subsidy which is another program within
the uh Division and it takes the
supplemental funding that we provide to
um someone who is awaiting a federal
voucher for what used to be known as
Section 8 housing it's a housing um
Choice voucher and now um we take that
and we incent landlords to rent to
individuals who are transitioning from
an inpatient setting and we've had um
those transitions happen so that when
someone is ready to be discharged from a
drf they're able to discharge and then
that opens up that bed for someone who's
in acute crisis um and so these six
drivers have really made a huge
difference and have allowed us to
achieve Mission zero on in points of
time and we've been able to sustain a
much lower weight list um and the time
that it takes from someone who lands in
an emergency department in an acute
crisis to get to a designating receiving
facility bed of which of course New
Hampshire hospital has um the largest
number um that time has been reduced
significantly so so we're really really
um pleased with the work Mission zero
remains something that we're always
striving toward so we can't say we're
done um but we continue to see the
results as um we have uh expanded and
enhanced and really focused on these six
areas representative tki for a question
followed by representative Stringham
thank you congratulations on uh the
department in getting this kind of um
progress um and hitting um that zero
weight which is excellent I am concerned
though um with the potential changes to
Medicaid if we could talk about the
number of people who are served that are
on Medicaid and
if there is a reduction in people who
actually have coverage how that would
affect Mission zero and your ability to
uh move people through the system
so I think um we're all concerned about
changes in Medicaid um Medicaid
underlies a lot of the services that are
provided from a programmatic standpoint
these are um significant uh Investments
that have been made and while we could
take any one of them and look at General
funds and then Medicaid funds it really
is intertwined and um important because
in order in in addition to these
Services there are just the regular
Services um the services by the
Community Mental Health Centers the
appointments the um ongoing uh assertive
Community treatment program um all of
those um could impact the population and
so we're closely monitoring that um I
believe that you heard from director
Litman every day um we have new
information or Chang information and we
continue to monitor monitor that very
closely um but we know that um anytime
we have someone who no longer has access
because of insurance coverage whatever
that is it's a missed opportunity and
it's
worrisome thank
you uh a question about uh the MH
supported housing inventory um uh can
you can you explain um
uh what support there is first in
constructing and making the inventory
available and then what the ongoing
costs are um uh to the state and to the
department to uh continue to have it be
used sure there are um different um
Financial um opportunities for the
development of the housing we have um
had um one-time funds the arpa funds
that I mentioned that we use very
strategically to build up our system
that were used for renovations for um
properties and um that either by our
community mental health centers or we
also have partnered with NFI North which
um has a number of uh settings across
the state for what's known as
transitional housing and there also is
the New Hampshire housing fin Authority
has the affordable housing fund that
looks at projects um such as those that
um provide for Supportive Housing um
across uh different populations so as
you may know they have certain
populations so aging population is one
that they um have as a priority as well
as individuals with uh behavioral health
conditions including mental health and
sud so that's for the actual Capital
costs and then the ongoing costs are
depending on the way that the program is
structured uh would depend so it could
be that it's Medicaid
reimbursable um or that it is um
something that's supported 100% General
funds um and there are the some of the
supporting suppor housing has
contributions by the
individuals so when I mentioned housing
Bridge subsidy it really is a subsidy it
doesn't fully um pay for rent but it
does it on a sliding fee
scale representative priest followed by
representative Neno thank you madam
chairman and and thank you uh Miss Fox
for taking my question again as I look
at um the Bureau of Mental Health
Services which this and many other
programs fall under it looks like it's
all federal funded is that
correct I'm looking on page
009 maybe some more to it sure that that
specific accounting unit that that's the
the mental health block grant and that's
100% federal funds in that specific
accounting unit yeah I I see on page 110
that you have General funds to it at 56
yes okay thank you for that
clarification thank you and and I think
another important thing um we are
talking about Mission zero here within
the division for Behavioral Health but
um there's elements of this that are
also uh involved with New Hampshire
hospital as well their staff play a role
in in the care traffic control
coordination and I know when Ellen Le
Point the CEO of New Hampshire hospital
will be here she'll be talking about
that as well and so this isn't just this
isn't just an initiative isolated to to
the division for Behavioral Health
there's a lot of other actors and
players and and their and other dollars
involved in other areas of the
department just because it's been such a
a wide wide- ranging strategic effort so
any funding effect on this from the
federal government government or from
the general fund would have uh
consequences
throughout um your
department there there could be
consequences yes if if there's a
reduction in funding towards this okay
larger initiative yes thank
you thank you uh Madam chair um I have
kind of a high level question here this
is a uh on page 33 is a 10year
representation of a 10year
plan and if I were looking at this from
a a budgeting and planning standpoint so
my first question would be you know
where we stand right now point in time
and if I were to look at this as a pie
chart what portion of resources is
allocated to each one of these uh six
different areas and then what's the
expectation over time as to how that how
that model would shift res resources I
mean I know that's a you know it's a a
30,000 foot level and maybe haven't
looked at it that way but
um I think at some point you would
expect if you're successful in some of
these areas you would see a you from a
planning standpoint in a budgetary
standpoint a shift in um in the resource
allocation great question and I'm glad
you brought up the 10-year plan which I
should have um uh in my initial comments
talked about that so the 10-year plan is
is was established in
2019 and it had front-loaded a lot of um
the
recommendations some of which are um a
you'll see the results of those
recommendations are in the programs have
been uh stood up and exist today
including mobile crisis and expanded
housing opportunities we had some
significant Medicaid rate increases that
were part of that plan um if you
Mission zero is you know a subpart of
that plan which is much more wide
ranging um and not specifically just to
address um emergency room boarding which
this is when we look um we are um we
could identify how many how much funds
go to each of these um what's important
to know is that if you take any one of
these away we would expect that we may
um Backtrack on that mission zero so
these need these are ongoing services
that we believe need to be supported um
we do know that the more that we're able
to build up the these Services the less
Reliance we're going to have on the um
higher level of care in a designated
receiving facility such as uh New
Hampshire hospital so we're trying to
decrease demand for that um while
increasing those community reports and
um this has been successful and um I
thank uh representative cherski for
congratulating the department but really
it's congratulating all of the community
providers um who've stood up these
services and have every day worked with
us um to address this need so I'm not
sure if I answered your question but be
happy to um clarify not directly but I
but I'll leave it for an now
okay you can say
it we're just
um trying to make sure that we address
that as far as um you know if you look
at this as a pie chart would we move
things around I think so I think we
wouldn't need to continue to expand drf
beds that we could move some of those
resources into the housing supports for
example um that would be one that we
could see um
so yeah what I was looking at is really
if if you're successful you know just
looking at this over the time span that
you're talking about the metrics H for
Success on this would suggest that you
you'd see a shift in you'd see savings
you'd see budgetary implications in each
one of these uh areas and you'd see
decided if you were successful in what
your goals and objectives are but that's
you know I said prepared to leave that
for now I I I think when when thinking
about savings um one important thing is
to sort of
understand you know where the 10year
mental health plan came from as far as
litigation other active litigation
against the state where we are not
satisfying the all of the needs out
there so when just thinking of it you
know in simple operating terms well you
may assume that there's some savings
there's also some other factors behind
the scenes that um that that exists
basically so it's not necessarily if you
invest now then you can save later um
it's part of it's looking at what was
occurring prior to doing these things
such as individuals waiting uh for care
and E boarding and where we've been able
to get that number down
significantly um that's not an area
where you can necessarily go back
because if you go back you're probably
going to end up in the same spot you
were
in thank you representative
priest thank you Madame chairman um
again on page uh
33 um do you have um you you mentioned
the success and
again as with my uh fellow
representative I do congratulate you uh
on these key Investments and what you
are doing do you have any numbers that
kind of
um yes show this and I would like to see
them and how far back do they go yeah so
um as Nathan mentioned you're going to
be hearing from New Hampshire hospital
we actually H uh publish a dashboard
that is live um and public facing that
we can get you the link to to where
you're able to see that data so we um
look at um the completion of a um
submission of a
involuntary emergency admission
paperwork and one um how long it takes
from that uh completed iea uh form to be
submitted to our care traffic control to
how long it takes to locate a drf that
can accept accept that uh person and so
we have all of those metrics you can see
the whole thing on the wait times the um
weight list and how that has changed
over time so we'll be happy to share
that with
Youk it's interesting because I've been
watching your sessions and so I pick up
on things that you're asking that are
going to be for me and now I'm doing
exactly the same thing oh wait until you
hear from this part of the department
not me but from them so it's interesting
how the can gets kicked um but we want
to make sure that as a department we're
answering all of your questions so um
bear with us as um we go through this
because um you will get your your
questions answered it just might not be
by me today
all right um slide 34 I'm going to
actually skip some of this because we
already talked about it um but it's the
um more detail about the
ccbhc clinics and what they are and um
how they um are different from cmhc's
but um are in how they are being stood
up one thing of note you're going to be
talking about hb2 I assume at some point
in time at the end of um hb1 going
through all these
presentations and um we have the
language um that I know that you talked
about I believe Nathan so that I could
explain it um where it talks about
weightless and it talks about
suspending um the um a particular state
law and that has been the prospective
appeal of the suspension of that law um
it gets very confusing but what it that
does what the current footnote does is
it allows the Community Mental Health
Centers to develop a weight list based
on funding um
availability because otherwise state law
indicates that they have to accept
anybody who is seeking Services
regardless of their ability to pay CC um
so that has been suspended so they have
been able to maintain that weight list
um and um help um stem some of their
operating losses with the ccbhc model um
in order to qualify for the federal
demonstration they do not have that
luxury so they are um we're closely
monitoring knowing this just went live
on on January 1st if they're seeing an
even more increased uh demand um that is
compensated so we're going to be
following that and and for for General
context and orientation it's on page uh
48 of the draft hb2 that you have and
it's entitled this section doesn't have
a number but it's entitled prospective
repeal regarding eligibility for
services extended and it's followed by
amend 2011 2096 uh and so forth but but
effectively what you're seeing in house
buil is as KATU was saying the effective
date of the original HB 191 from 2011 is
being extended out to July 1st of
2027 and the reason why I raise it here
again is that the ccbhcs will not be
able to take advantage of that because
of the federal demonstration the
requirement by CMS that they accept all
um of those who um come to to their
doors for
services so that's where the
uncompensated care discussion of that $5
million of prioritized need comes into
play um so I'm GNA again I'm going to
skip through this if you have questions
about
ccbhc please let me know and stop me um
I think we'll go to slide 37 if that's
okay so this is to improve
access um for
services and this is very specific to
those um who are on Medicaid but you
don't open up um a service based um like
a a Community Mental Health Center
doesn't say okay your Medicaid and your
XYZ they're going to um evaluate the
patient needs so that's what um this is
looking at um while it's AIC a
demonstration it does require us to
serve um everybody who comes through the
doors there's a certification process we
received as um a department a Federal
grant so that we could set up that
certification process and that is what
Manchester and nashaa um achieved um and
that's what West Central behavioral
health is going through right
now and the idea is that people have
access and there'll be um high quality
services and it will focus on that care
cordination and um that we should see as
part of mission zero and as part of this
demonstration a decreased demand for
acute level
Services um and slide 38 strong as
Granite this is some of the media that
we we use as part of that
campaign Suicide Prevention we've talked
about that we are going to get that
report to you um and this is um part of
that which is the 988 and ways to
address um that prevention
effort and I will pause there and then
go on do representative Daniels for a
question thank you do you coordinate
with the VA at all we do so the VA has a
special
um response and a team of uh call center
staff who who are specifically um
well-versed in veterans um matters and
so yes we very much do and they are part
of our uh 988 steering committee and our
our subgroups so yes do your statistics
on on uh Suicide Prevention include the
VA yes yes so we can actually break out
um from 98 988 how many um people whove
accessed those Services um have gone
through the the specialized veteran line
so yes it it is a population that we pay
special uh special attention to
all
right so I think we have two more
bureaus to go so
halfway Bureau of homeless
services so the Bureau of homeless
Services joined us um about three years
ago I believe um with a recognition that
many of the um issues are um that
homelessness is a factor with mental
health and substance use conditions and
vice versa um and so we wanted to uh
fold in homeless Services into our
division and to address those
needs the uh accounting
units so we're looking at the path Grant
this is a grant and um we'll get a
little bit more into this but this is we
contract with four Community Mental
Health Centers to provide these services
the next
um accounting unit is the housing and
shelter program this houses uh our
contracts for um state grants in Aid
which is all the homeless shelters that
we fund across the state um and we'll um
talk about that but under prioritized
needs This was um
under uh Senate Bill 406 last session we
received uh $2.5 million to increase the
rates for shelters and we were able to
do that and in the governor's budget it
is funded um to continue those rates at
that level so that prioritized need was
submitted and picked up and is in the
budget that you're looking
at also in this account our our um
federal funds from housing and uh Urban
Development and our emergency Solutions
Grant again I'll go into these programs
but those those are funded out of this
account representative tarki for a
question hi thank you um on page
1012 um can we look at I think it's line
102 and discuss the bill that this
division has been looking at regarding
the Waypoint Youth Shelter Services
there's been some confusion of people
saying it's included in the budget it's
not included in the budget and if it is
in the budget do we need to specify it's
going to
Waypoint so it it's in the budget it is
in that budget line it's in um 102 as
are those um that prioritize needs for
the shelter program so yes the half
million per year is in this budget I
have another
question if I remember correctly it was
also in last year's budget but they
didn't receive the funds which is why we
had this bill
filed they so um they did receive the
funds um that were um part of I'm trying
to think of where they came in but they
were part of um an allocation that was
made um they and this just continues
that funding so the bill um at the same
time we put it in as a prioritized need
there was also the separate bill to fund
them same dollar amounts which is why I
think you've seen and heard some
different things but right now the half
million dollars that we had previously
funded them at um that they're currently
um under contract to receive uh is
continued through this budget as it is
today okay so you're saying we don't
need to specify anything hb1 that
determines the money goes to Waypoint
young adult
shelter
um there'd be nothing prohibiting you
from putting a class note in there
saying of the $500,000 budget in each
year the buy 500,000 she go to Waypoint
for the purposes of providing you
shelter I guess I'm just trying to get
back to the original discussion from
maybe two months ago when that bill was
filed to oh I am so glad glad the door
just
opened representative walner we're
discussing um shelter and
Waypoint on page 41 of our PowerPoint
not to put you on the spot um but to
bring you up to speed um the wayo half a
million dollar a year funding is
included in hb1 which I think we're all
thrilled to find out um we're just
discussing if we feel that there needs
to an amendment for a class note that
specifies the allocation to Waypoint so
I don't know if you would have any
questions to dig into
that I think it's something we should
discuss about um really noting in the
budget that it is for Waypoint or I
don't
know okay sure yeah and this was um this
was a uh prioritized need of the
department for this bium so there is
that record but we've certainly had
instances in the current bium where
something as as representative teris is
uh suggesting where it clearly specifies
that that money is intended for this
Purpose with this provider so okay great
thank you representative Neno for
question yeah I'm so I'm confused so
that means we don't need the bill that
was filed for that
that's what we're sorry that's what
we're trying to determine so if it's if
it's included in the budget and if we uh
somehow get a note in some kind of a
note in there that says it's
specifically in the budget for that
purpose then that would make the the
bill moot right so we'll probably
discuss it at a future date when we're
looking digging into doing amendments
but it's my understanding it was the
specifying that it's supposed this
amount is supposed to go to this
particular service was the question so
I'm sure we'll talk about it down the
road yeah we just want to make sure
we're not not double it won't be double
I assure you so it sounds like this note
that's referred to uh would amend the
bill would replace it essentially in
order to make clear where the money is
allocated in the budget or would it add
to
it it would depend so if you itl the
other Bill and you added a class note
directly in the department to um use
those funds in whatever specified amount
the
500,000 um then the bill wouldn't be
needed um but I'll I'll defer to the the
committee on that okay representative
Walder on this topic and then
representative priest yes on this topic
so I think the practice at the finance
committee in the past on situations like
this where there was a bill and then
there was an appropriation in the budget
usually we have retained the
bill that means the bill doesn't go
forth it just stays right here in the
finance committee and then the budget we
roll the amount into the budget we
retain the bill once the budget is
completed in June we would still have
the bill as retained but we would report
it out next year as inexpedient to
legislate so that we haven't given up
the bill to only to find out I mean if
the if
the finance committee leaves it in the
budget and we send it over to the Senate
and they take it
out then we might lose it as long as we
as long as we're still in possession of
the bill we might be able to do
something with it in the next
year okay thanks for the clarification
for a newcomer to the whole process here
thank you representative priest for
question I want to thank representative
wallers for coming in and explaining
that that was my question about that
retention would be the best option uh at
this time and instead of it Ling it but
I did have another question regarding um
on
page
1013 no I'm sorry um on on 1011 when it
talks about the funding for this
division it shows that um you are
getting uh $5
million um from a federal source and
then you're going to be transferring
that $5
million um I'm sorry it's on page
1012 estimate a source of
funding transfer from other agencies and
then you'll be taking it away can you
explain that for for me
please sure so the transfer from other
agency line what that represents is that
represents a $5 million transfer from
the opioid abatement trust fund okay and
that is located there's a corresponding
provision on page 47 of the draft hb2
document that you have that provides for
that
uh for that transfer there okay and
those dollars are being moved to support
the um the SGI the the shelter
contracts as um there is a there's a a a
a a correlation between opioid use
disorder or risk of opioid use disorder
um for for members of of that population
and that that's
that that was added during the
governor's phase and and the general
fund uh portion of that was was reduced
from the agency to the governor's phase
there okay so then you have less funds
for budgeted budgeted Revenue transfers
and it's it looks like you've taken the
$5 million out again and I'm confused
about that can you clarify that so
that that is put in and take it out sure
so
so that that's being removed so that
it's not counted twice in the budget
because those dollars should show up
somewhere else within the budget okay I
see traditionally um this is a unique
case because the opioid Batman trust
fund is not included in the budget but
when I had conversations with the
Department of administrative Services
they verified that it should be showing
up that way okay thank you
representative Neno for a question quick
qu quick question on the
uh page 41 where we're looking at the
housing and shelter program and it says
20% other funds is that what we're just
talking about here with the with the
five million oh okay that's what I
thought it was thank you representative
seaworth thank you very much um I'd like
to look back up uh the line 72 74102
with the asterisk um it looks like
there's been some movement between lines
and I'm trying to understand what stayed
the same and what's different
there
so if you look at class
103 there's there's or excuse me class
102 you see uh 4.9 million adjusted
authorized and then when you scroll over
you see
7.9 next to that SB 406 uh appropriated
$2.5 million of General funds and when
we prepare our budget we prepare we do
the the reconciliation the history for
the adjusted authorized in August and
the I don't believe the legislation
either there was a delay in signature
doesn't always take effect July 1 and
then there's also a process after that
where we go to the Department of
administrative services with a memo to
accept those dollars into our budget so
the $2.5 million is not being recognized
there what's also not being recognized
there is the
$500,000 that was added for the use
shelter program that we were just
discussing and let me see here and then
[Music]
there's okay and then
and I would have to dig into let's see
here and
then there's also some movement
from from class 74 so class 74 I'm I'm
going to go on kind of it's kind of an
esoteric subject but it's important for
this committee to
understand when when we receive federal
dollars we have to make a determination
when we enter into an agreement as to
whether it should be considered a
subrecipient or a contractor
simplistically a subrecipient provides
services on behalf of the department and
under 2 CFR 2 200 through 31 there's
certain criteria that are used to make a
determination on that and we need to
track that approach appropriately and so
we use different class Lines within the
budget to to make sure that if it's uh
if it's federal funds and they're a
subrecipient we need to track those in a
certain class line versus a contractor
uh a contractor is um a scenario where
they provide services to the department
so that may be like they're building a
website for us they're maintaining a
system for us that that's the simplistic
way to to think about those two
determinations so I know that there is
some movement between those lines for
that purpose to reconcile uh some of
that as well but um if you'd want a more
detailed history or or crosswalk I mean
we can do that as well similar to uh to
what we discussed yesterday on another
topic thank you mostly I wanted um the
high level
explanation uh that you gave and and
thank you I don't know other members
may may be interested in the details
yeah I I just think it would be helpful
to if that's included in the crosswalk
exercise that we're doing to kind of
help clarify what's moving
where sure we we can do one for for this
accounting unit as well and easy
representative
priest thank you madam chairman my
question was align with my fellow
representative so it's been answered
thank
you all set
okay oh representative tersi sort of
circling back to sp46 and the increase
rates for daily rates for the beds um I
believe we increased it to $27 a day um
do we have do you I don't expect you to
have hard numbers but any idea on the
impact of that and if it was helpful to
the
providers knowing it's probably still
short yes and yes um the impact was
great um as we heard um they just the
increased cost that they have for
everything like we have all experience
with electricity and food and all of
that that helped um offset some of those
costs as well as Staffing and they
talked about um the need for maintaining
staff um and how they could use those
funds to do that so yes it did have a
good impact um I'm sure that they could
use more because I think that um $27 a
day is still um lower than what they
expend um and they do significant uh
fundraising for the remaining of those
funds and other grants that they get
from the community but it did make a
difference and it made a difference
enough that that's why we asked for the
prioritized need and most importantly
why the governor recognized that to that
it was really important to maintain that
rate the that's good to hear um do you
have any thoughts about people who
aren't being able aren't being served
and any even anecdotal stories um in
general areas of people who can't be
served because there's no
openings I would um defer to the
providers to be able to talk about um
these circumstances under which someone
is not able to um receive uh the
services and be able to have a bed so to
speak um because they're going to be on
the front line and be able to have that
um and I think that um continuing these
rates is a way to ensure that the beds
that we do fund 934 of them are
available and that we don't lose uh
ground thank you representative priest
thank you Madame chairman and thank you
Miss uh Fox um question you mentioned
something about you're receiving a HUD
funds where's is that uh on the budget
you mentioned 5 thou $5 million or
something you wish so I didn't site a
number um and the um we do receive um
HUD funding um for our sis or uh our
um blanking on the community of care the
COC funds Continuum of Care funds from
HUD and we receive some um other
funding I don't know if um Nathan could
um specify where it is and it shows up
in the budget book um but we're going to
talk a little bit more about that as we
go through uh the bureau sure it's it's
on page 102 okay the the the federal
funds line there is is the um continu of
care and uh ESG dollars there so that
would would include Medicaid and HUD
funding is there any other Federal
funding in that there there there's
there's no Medicaid dollars there no
Medicaid no
oh so that 11 million is all HUD is that
what you're saying
Umar Sam show up there I I believe there
there's a small portion of other federal
funds but um the vast majority of it is
HUD funding um
this particular uh contract has uh I
don't know off the top of my head but
probably north of 30 or 40 different
contracts um that are that are funded
out of this and some of those are coming
uh through HUD for the Continuum of Care
and those um there's some small Grant
dollars there's also some hopwa dollars
in there as well um that have very
specific requirements and they're on
different time frames and Grant periods
and and you'll see those go through GNC
uh two three times a year depending on
how many updates we we have to those
those Awards okay thank you very much
for the
clarification all right um so I on slide
42 the UN numbered page uh really
talking about the service system um
we're looking at at Community Education
and awareness the entry point for
homeless Services is
211 um and so people are able to access
housing and homeless Services through
that and then we have the Continuum of
Care that supports a coordinated entry
system and we have what many of you are
aware of uh is the point in time uh
homeless count um that we do on a
particular day in January and we um use
those numbers uh to establish funding uh
throughout the state for our shelter
programs so it's an very important count
um that many people are involved in at
the at the community and Regional
level we have prevention and early
intervention so housing
stabilization which um provides
shortterm rental assistance and
supportive
services repres to ask a question nenco
just as a you know a point of Interest
point in time how is that how is that
conducted that's a very good question so
all of the shelters and our Outreach
workers um are asked to participate and
um they
they report out on how many people are
in their shelters um and then we have
the Outreach that looks at unhoused
individuals as well people who aren't in
any shelter who yeah so for example I
know in the Keen area there's some you
know encampments and and and that sort
of thing so how are you you know so
there how are you picking those numbers
up it it is amazing how our communities
know who and the Rapport that they have
with those individuals so able to go out
and and have those um and and account
for individuals who aren't in a homeless
shelter thank
you okay and Community Based Services
and support so we talked about emergency
shelter um the path workers in the
community mental health centers they're
the ones who are going out um we have
again we have four um centers that have
that specific
specialization with those
workers um and then um that's funded as
we said in the path grant that you saw
in the accounting
unit the Continuum of Care funded
projects so they provide permanent
supported housing rapid rehousing which
is we get somebody quickly um into
housing um and keep them in housing we
have youth transitional
housing and that was a specific Grant um
and then we have the um homeless
management information system that's our
data platform and that all of our
contracted providers submitt data to us
so that we are able to break down um you
know age
demographics and gender and really uh
see what's happening in that um in the
homeless
system and then we have again homeless
prevention we'll go more into this um
and that streight out
reach right so we are at page
43 this goes more into point in time and
how that is counted um and we do go
through a period of time everyone uh
starts calling us um in February asking
what the count was for this year we do
go through a cleaning of the data to
make sure that we're not duplicating
data and that we're UND duplicating it
so it takes a little bit for us to
actually have that count and we do use
that count in formulas for how we're
going to allocate funds um to our
shelter programs in our uh winter
emergency um
Sheltering representative ters ask you
for a
question can you um explain to me I
understand you people who are sheltered
you have to have a bed to be sheltered
right so the the drop from 2023 to 24
that wasn't necessarily A Drop in beds
available it was a drop in persons
utilizing those beds
correct or am I wrong no I think I
understand your question and I think
you're correct yes okay
okay representative priest for a
question thank you madam chairman on
that same chart on
43 can you explain why there was this
sharp rise in
2023 followed by
2024 sure so we had um the housing
program that was through the federal
government that uh provided the funding
for I forgot what the name of the
program was so I'm sure people are
shouting behind me and I'm going to get
all kinds of uh messages but there was
the um housing program that was run
through the cap agencies okay that um
then that program wound down so that um
is where we did not have um so we had
people that were counted as um sheltered
that became
unsheltered um in the next count and so
um that was rentals and hotels and uh
different types of solutions that were
were um
made okay thank you very much
representative Stringham for question
since uh since these counts are done in
odd years and in January uh will has the
20 uh 25 uh census been completed is it
a
yes and as I said it usually takes us a
few months to clean the data and to get
it um
unduplicated and so we will get
preliminary numbers soon in the next
probably by April um they're not usually
published until later in the year but we
start sharing what those uh numbers are
the um unofficial numbers as um soon as
we feel comfortable being able to so I I
don't have that information for you to
today unfortunately yeah I I don't know
if you've glanced at it but it you know
preliminarily unofficial not finished uh
is there anything in there that you
think might be um uh valuable to those
of us on finance
committee I literally have not seen any
numbers so I don't know and I haven't
heard even um reports so um I don't have
information to share with you
today probably before the um budget
wraps up um then we'll have we'll have
that
number okay all right so page
44 so this is the homelessness
prevention and this is a way to catch
people before they lose their housing um
and so there's rental assistance and
Supportive Services the ideas if you
keep somebody housed um then they uh can
go on and have um that more
self-sufficiency whereas if they lose
housing it is so hard for them to gain
it back um in any way shape or form so
we have these
projects um and you can see the numbers
that have been served by that um and you
can see the age de
demographics and that ties back to that
really important data management system
that we have um so that's how we're able
to share this information with you and
then we have the exits from this program
to permanent housing um which is at a
very high
rate page
45 so we continue to talk about the
prevention um um and these oh I'm sorry
this is the duplication that I was
talking about Pages 44 and 45 are the
same exact and in the meantime we have a
question by representative priest great
thank you uh Madam chairman and thank
you for taking my question how do you um
eliminate the duplication on your
homeless numbers from the state and
versus the local
um cuz person may be facing homeless he
goes to his wh Ware officer of the
community and we don't is that
coordinated yeah so it's a coordinated
approach um the state doesn't do the
count the communities do the count so
that's another way to um have that
quality assurance um but to the actual
matching um and determinations of
unduplicated I would need to check with
my staff to see how they do that but
it's a pretty rigorous process because
you don't want to overstate or
understate um the status of the
population representative walner for a
question thank you so I noticed
on page 44 that you have it broken down
by age for the homeless
prevention but I wondered if on on the
point of time count do you count
children do you have a count of how many
children how many adults yes you do and
families yes thank you representative
tarki for a question how do you handle
situations where homeless family may be
living in a hotel or a motel or or with
family couch surfing kind of thing how
do you even do that we do and we do it
through the service providers so if
they're known to the community it may be
as mentioned Town welfare um may have um
helped support somebody in a hotel um
there's couch surfing that goes on and
again we uh rely on our service
providers our communities our um any
touch point along the way to help us
identify that schools are included as
well oh good okay representative PRI for
a question as a continuation from the
question raised by the representative
before me uh this also includes
nonprofits agencies like Family Promise
in conquer
yeah okay great thank you absolutely
yes churches are a a great source of
information all right
47 I think that's where I am
right oh I'm sorry we're on 46 right
yeah 46 I think it just started 46 okay
all
right um so Emergency Shelters we've
been talking a lot about that um and um
we do differentiate um with chronically
homelessness which is um the length of
time that someone has been uh homeless
we look at families um and we look at
Veterans as well so we do break down
that data so that we know um that is a
big effort that has been made across the
state most notably nashaa and Manchester
have uh taken steps to uh really reach
out to that population and it has made a
difference um in keeping those numbers
um low and obviously we want them to be
zero but um there has been significant
promise in those communities that have
focused on that
population all right 47
representative priest for a
question yes back in 46 When you mention
unique households what do you mean by
unique unique means um
unduplicated so
individual all right so the path workers
this is the um individuals who are at
the community menta health centers and
this shows their
statistics um and how um referrals are
made the program uh enrollment the
demographics um
and um anything else about that program
um is included here and when um they
received and attained um that
housing all right are we ready to move
on to the Bureau of drug and alcohol
services our last Bureau ready to move
on
okay so we'll go to the accounting units
on page
49 um the program operations there are
no contracts that are associated with
that that's for
Staffing the block grant um oh I'm sorry
I'm supposed to give the page number so
um
992 is is where that starts if you want
to orient yourself to
that the um block rant so samama has two
different block rants they have the one
for substance uh misuse and they have
the one for mental health services
you're now seeing the one that is uh for
this program
area and we have multiple contracts that
um are funded uh through this and I
again I have this list of 21 Pages worth
of contracts and um can dig that up if
you have specific questions about where
the funding goes for that
same thing with Prevention Services um
that's General funds keeping in mind
with our block grant funds that we have
to have a maintenance of effort so when
you see that there are General funds
that are expended those are very
important to help support our federal
funds in maintain that level we are able
to claim the what we spend in general
funds on Medicaid as part of our
maintenance of effort um which has been
helpful in um maintaining um the two
years of um keeping the same level of
General funds that are spent over that
two-year period to match the significant
federal dollars representative Nano for
question yes thank you madam chair um
this a a a general question on contracts
and are these uh typically multi-year
contracts or oneyear contracts with a
with a renewal clause in them uh and are
are I I suppose there's some performance
metrics attached to the contract so
maybe just take a couple of minutes to
describe uh the whole um uh Universe of
uh contracts absolutely so there are um
different ways everything you mentioned
is um a potential so we do have one-year
contracts um depending on the funding
source and the expectation of what we're
buying with that contract um more likely
for example we have treatment contracts
um so those are your um contracts that
when someone has either inpatient
treatment or outpatient treatment and
they contract with the state um and with
this division those are more likely to
be multi-year so that um we typic Ally
align and do renewal options with our
state funding so with your budget with a
two-year budget um we look and we know
that we can put those funds into
contract and then we have renewal
options that can be adjusted based on
the level of funds that we have we um
know the burden that is placed on our
providers from um having to contract
um and what that process is like it's
pretty uh
intense um and so we try to have
especially with contractors that we know
have good performance outcomes and uh
meet our metrics and meet our their
obligations under the contract we try to
uh stretch it out Beyond two years um
but that's that it really depends on on
what the contract is for and for how
long and what funding source
okay thank
you and um oversight when we're talking
about Staffing in any one of these areas
that really is um how we uh oversee um
with the staff is they have contracts so
we have in um Bas specifically we have
units and they oversee those um
contracts so there is a clinical unit
that oversees the treatment contct
contracts there's a prevention unit that
oversees their prevention contract so we
have it um so that people really can be
specialized um in knowing their
contracts and being responsible for that
so if I have a question about a contract
I know who to call because that's their
contract that they're
overseeing and managing thank
you representative seaworth for a
question thank you very much um when I
look at let me make sure I'm in the
right line yeah
3380 and that has the um
four uh individuals overseeing those
contracts it looks to me like the
governor's budget reduced that to one or
am I is it moved no so it's moved so if
you look at page
994 within the the 3168 sap block grant
account you'll see 10 positions 10
permanent classified positions there so
four of them came from accounting unit
3384 three of them came from accounting
unit
3380 and then three of them came from
accounting unit 2070 so we we were we
were moving and consolidating those
positions into a single accounting unit
here that's 100% federal
funds and because I was figuring out
where I was the first accounting unit
that the four were moved from was
3384 3384 yeah thank you of course
representative
nalen yeah um just a quick uh followup
to uh Brian's question representative
seaworth um that'll be in this crosswalk
exercise that that you're doing you know
so that we can we we can prepare one for
this as well yeah because it's uh I
think it'll make it much much easier for
everybody to uh be able to track all of
the inter departmental movements on
these funds uh so we'd appreciate that
yeah sure sure we we can prepare one
specific to this as well um we we don't
plan on preparing one for the entire
budget but if there's specific areas
that you're interested in please let me
know and and I think one one kind of
important thing I I I always try to put
myself in your shoes and just sort of
like imagine like how hard it is to look
at this thing and be like oh what's
going on here um during the year we we
make in February of every even numbered
year we have an opportunity to kind of
review the way that we are accounting
for things and and we do try to make
changes um and and it's it's it's quite
intentional it may be for operational
needs it may be to isolate specific
funding sources to make it a little
easier to track sometimes it's auditor
suggestion because they don't like the
way we may mix General and federal funds
in the same account kind of depends so
so there's a lot of reasons for why we
do those things I just want to make it
clear that like we're we're not trying
to make it harder to follow or anything
like that and we'll prepare whatever you
need so you can kind of follow the
bouncing ball yeah I think is the other
day I said I like apples I like oranges
but I hate proof
though representative priest for a
question thank you Madame chairman and
thank you for taking my question um back
to the uh
alcoholic and substance abuse program
um yeah the the numbers of those of the
clients that are requesting services are
alarming and um we me we talked about
this briefly but what in the budget do
you have for Recovery houses to make
sure that the patients that come out of
treatment don't go back on the streets
again and have to repeat this again and
again and they're safe for a while until
they can get their um their act
together so I can take that now or um
when we go into in the next couple
slides um but I know that this is um an
area of your interest in so um we have
recovery housing um there are different
types of recovery housing um and I can
explain some of it um some uh right now
and some of it is respit um some of it
for somebody um so under the state
opioid response Grant which you will see
on the next slide which is under the
accounting unit um
7040 we have um the we had the
opportunity to fund a couple of programs
where there is respit for someone who
calls 211 or goes through a doorway and
is um needing treatment but can't get
into treatment for a couple days perhaps
because they have to get all their
paperwork in place or they need um to
settle matters and and get um admitted
and during that time they can go into
respit so that's one way um that we help
um as people are awaiting that
transition into treatment
for Recovery housing we have um
different programs we have a certifying
body which certifies recovery housing
and in order for them uh a recovery
house to get a referral um from the
state and from the doorway they need to
have gone through that certification
process um so we oversee that and that
um provides standards by which these
recovery houses have to abide by in
order to be referred get referrals um so
that um so that people can um use State
dollars to um be in that housing um
there are so many different types of
recovery housing across the state um
there are private entities I I think
many of you have them in your
communities or have heard about them in
your districts um and um they're all
different models um one of the other
aspects of recovery housing any that is
state funded um must be able to um have
individuals who may be using medication
for addiction treatment they have to
allow that so if there is um a
philosophy that people should be absent
only including medications for addiction
treatment then we're not going to be
able to support them in those funds um
and I'll stop
there thank you representative tersi for
a question thank you um I'm looking at
the Prevention Services
3380 I don't know if we've quite gotten
there in your your line but we're sort
of talking about this um the bottom of
um the budget page 995 they're is um
organization notes with uh four
different organizations I was um
involved with getting that in here last
bium so I'm a little confused by the
asterik on line 074 and the fact that
the note refers to class 102 so can you
just explain if the funds from last bium
made it into this year's budget or not
thanks the short answer is yes okay um
yes they did make it in so this carries
that forward and the governor included
it in her
budget the there I I I just I want to
verify this but I do believe that there
is one subtle change it's the five
versus um in the in the current bium
there were five organizations that were
identified in the in in the in the
original legislation and it was $40,000
each year for each of those
organizations and in the current
Governor's recommended budget um there
are four organizations listed when
following um the passes of chapter 106
laws of 2023 one of the organizations
chose not to accept the dollars and so
that's been accounted for in the current
bium
interesting representative Stringham for
a question
yeah so I'll jump around to 3382 the
governor's
commission um in the um briefing book uh
it talks about the number um uh being
served uh or the case load is
44,000 in the current bium and that
jumps to
60,000 um in in the um in the the budget
that we're working on uh with
essentially no change in authorization
is there are we finding that there's
less intensive services that are still
just as effective for the people or or
um was there tremendous un unmet uh need
or you know what what's driving this
change thank you for the question I'll
bring that back to see the change um I
it could be in what was funded and how
many people the reach is in that
particular um
area sure sure um what one important
thing about this accounting unit uh for
for the Governor's commission funds is
the the agency
income this
represents uh 5% of the gross profits of
of the Liquor
Commission and and and and that that
that went into being um last last spum
and so the these are estimated Revenue
amounts included there based on the
estimates that came from The Liquor
Commission so so so so the the funding
here is not necessarily what what might
be the need but it's what's projected
and that's that's uh specified in in
State
law can I ask a question so I I guess
the question I have if if the annual
cost per case is $250 under the current
bium and the projected is to decrease to
178 uh in the next
bium you know is is that is that really
realistically enough money for that
those services to be provided or we
providing different services that are
less expensive so I think it has to do
with the types of services that were
funded under the governor's commission
so if they change um their funding in
from you know serving a 100 people and
then they choose an initiative that
serves a thousand people you're going to
see that difference but let me take that
back um these are as as Nathan said
these are estimates um and so it may be
that we don't end up serving 60,000 it
may be closer to the 44 and really when
we talk about Prevention Services those
are really estimated um when we talk
about the reach of a particular program
when it's to a broad
audience representative tersi for
question thank you um it's my
understanding that a few days ago
another division was was looking into
And discussing um the liquor fund and
where the money goes would you speak um
about the governor's Commission on
Alcohol and Other Drugs and describe the
oversight of those funds and and how
they're used absolutely so the
governor's commission is in statute um
and so all of its um obligations and
what it does is defined um in that
statute the um
it is um determined who's on the
commission is uh listed in that statute
so that includes appointments from um
the governor and specific uh Le um seats
that are designated for example the uh
Commissioner of Health and Human
Services the commissioner of safety the
commissioner of Education all sit at
that table um people with lived
experience their um representation from
recovery
uh uh and from other types of programs
um I serve as the executive director of
the governor's commission by Statute and
so um that
is part of um the attachment that they
have we we administer um the and carry
out the wishes of the governor's
commission the governor's commission um
is extremely transparent and because of
questions that came up from fiscal
committee a number of years ago you will
find in the operating statistics in the
dashboard um for every single month of
fiscal committee we provide where we are
all the status of every single contract
um that is funded by the governor's
commission the governor's commission
provides annual reports courts um we
have a strategic plan and we have um
members of the legislature who serve on
that commission um it is a high
functioning mature group um that not
only um makes decisions based on um
their own self-interest but we have had
sessions listening sessions going out
across the state um to hear from people
about where they think the gaps are um
and we just did that last year um very
informative um and really helps us build
our strategic plan and Target uh dollars
towards those gaps one of the benefits
of the governor's commission is that its
funds are flexible so we have we've been
going through you know we have the block
grant that has us set aside for a
certain amount of dollars we have
obligations under and all the strings
that come with Federal funding the
governor's commission has more
flexibility um but it also has
accountability um and um I I
just think um that it is an example of
how we can structure such commissions
that have that funding Authority and
that um appropriation Authority uh I
mean a allocation Authority um um and so
that's I hope that answered it and I
know Nathan wants to add something yeah
I I think one one other important thing
to understand is once that commission
makes their decisions on what should be
funded katu's team members of my team
then develop the contracts using the
standard contract process and template
that we use where there's performance
metrics we look at deliverables we look
at the payment terms and then once those
um get approved and all of our contracts
are scrutinized by the governor and ex
Ive counselors then those services are
delivered and then they go through the
standard monthly review process where
we're verifying that the services are
received and we generally do not pay
anything for a cost reimbursement based
contract or other deliverable contract
if the services um are not are not
demonstrated and delivered so there's
also sort of the the micro Level side of
it both both at the global when the
decisions are made but then once we
actually Implement and operationalize it
there's the same level of scrutiny
applied to that as any of our other
contracts and grants and we also do um
often go out to bid for um those
services with um the governor's
commission identifying that they want a
particular type of service um provided
but um we we issue an RFP so that um
there's opportunity for um Community
organizations to um put in their
applications for
that I appreciate that explanation
so any other views that for some reason
These funds are not being managed
properly it goes through data driven um
metrics the same way other spending does
for the Department um perhaps we just
have to share this tape and and help
help them better understand how that
works so thank you for
that representative n valeno
foreno yeah I so that's kind of new to
me
uh and I think you said 5% of the Liquor
Commission sales are allocated to that
fund and so the the question is this is
a fund that's
constantly receiving funds I don't I I
would assume on a monthly or a quarterly
basis and there's a budget for the uh uh
Governor's commission and to the extent
that that's over under so I would assume
that you're you're that fund always has
a positive balance is that is that
correct so yes um however we do again
during that um monthly report and we um
share this with the fiscal committee and
we also have the dashboard that we share
with the governor's commission that
shows what they've what's been carried
forward so this is a non-aps fund what's
been carried forward but what also has
been obligated so they're making
spending decisions usually twice a year
if something unusual comes up they'll
make um a special you know they'll do it
in an off time um of those two meetings
um however they
um we that balance is always known um
and right now for example um with the
anticipated funding um or the actual
funding and the allocations that have
been made by the commission so it takes
time for us to go into contract um and
so they may have voted to direct funds
to a specific type of service but for us
to be able to execute upon that may take
several months so right now for example
sitting here today we have about $1.4
million that is
unallocated um and um that is available
for consider ation for spending the
commission has taken a conservative
approach that in that it wants to have a
little bit of a balance to account for
an emergent situation so if we have
something that um really needs a
response they like to have the
flexibility to be able to respond to
that um so they don't want to spend it
down to zero we have gone um to half a
million before um but yes and um from
The Liquor Commission as as to we always
have these replenished funds I believe
that they make um the payments to us
twice a
year so so you roughly have a target for
what you'd like to see as a unallocated
unallocated balance at you know on on an
ongoing basis again varies by whatever
the the needs are yeah I think um it's
um it's not um uncommon for it to be
around 10% but again it can dip below
that and if there is an unmet need and
we know there are dollars there they're
going to allocate
it a related question and probably
because I haven't kept up with it but
there was a tobacco settlement fund
right and not is that totally gone or is
that still something that's out there as
well
we typically do not use the T the
tobacco settlement funds for public
health or other um primary Prevention
Services there are small amounts that
may fund individual things but as a
whole the tobacco settlement funds
typically go into the general fund
although um i' I'd be happy if someone
else uh knew more than
that okay thank
you all set all right so I think we're
still we're uh page 50 um and we're
going through we should have said at the
outset and I apologize because you had
to raise it um yourselves but we did do
a lot of work in um cleaning up these
accounting units because of what um uh
Nathan said about really being able to
identify for Grant purposes and
Reporting um it is much cleaner to have
100% federal funds in an accounting unit
and then 100% General funds and so the
team that is here with Nathan and me
today um took a a considerable amount of
time to move those funds around and
you're seeing that in your budget pages
so I apologize for not raising that but
thank you for noting
it um so drug forfeiture this is when we
get a um% of when there has been um a
seizure and um a through um a criminal
activity and there's the for fiter of um
the goods so to speak those uh funds are
given to us and put into this account by
Statute um and so we're able to use
those it's not a lot of money um but it
is
available State opioid response Grant um
this is the funding that comes from
SSA and this has been in play for
several years we are in year four of
allocation from this uh Grant and it
runs around $28 million a year it is
categorical in that we have very
specific areas that we are allowed and
not allowed to spend this fun these
funds on
one key component um that is loosened up
a little bit but still remains is that
it's for services for individuals with
opioid use disorder um and so um or at
risk um of opioid use disorder this
funds are doorway systems uh system
across the state so are nine doorways
that we have um and it funds a number of
programs um they have specific
populations that they want to have
addressed um including Justice involved
and um pregnant moms um
parenting um uh you people who are
parenting um and we use it in about 30
contracts we're in the process of doing
the renewal with the latest funding that
we received
in uh the last quarter of last uh
calendar year and I can see a question
Brewing it's sorry it's sorry brooded
representative Neno yeah I'm looking at
a big drop in those numbers from you
know um on I'm on page 998 and I think
I'm looking at the current expenses 02
on state opio opio response Grant goes
from a you million four down to pretty
much smaller numbers
what's the what's the story behind
that I'm on page 998 of
the governor's budget just looking at
line 20 yeah line
20 oh that's the the the the current
expense line there yeah
yeah
so
C you want
I don't think it is is it what that I
don't think it is I don't know what
current expens
is about where did they
go you're
talking I think for this we're going to
dial a
friend so I'm going to ask our finance
director um for the division um um to uh
approach and uh if Kyra Leonard could um
help us with this
sure she she didn't come to spend all
day without
speaking and if you could just introduce
yourself for the record um Kyra Leonard
I'm the finance director for the
division for Behavioral Health sorry
welcome thanks um and we're looking at
the class 20 and 74 so um the reason why
it's so high with the actuals in um
fiscal year 2024 is we ended up buying
uh a large amount of nooc zone for
distribution into the community to
increase saturation um and then it went
down because um we're accounting for
buying additional but not to that
extent
so so I I think we saw this was was on
and grants to communities across New
Hampshire is that what happened
there oh is that a question for oh yeah
would you uh yield to a
question so I can answer that so um so
we purchased n lockone and so we had n
lockone in every doorway budget where
they would um make their own purchases
and then we as a state made this
particular purchase of
Noone uh the um reversal drug um and um
the contracts that we're talking out uh
about show up in other uh class lines so
that that's something that our local
communities would have seen so for
example in my town we have an ambulance
Corp and I think I remember something
about saying that they were you um uh
stocking everything with uh with that
particular drug is that where that would
have come from so some of it yes um some
of the private um so the communities
already have um a variety of um
Pharmaceuticals that they need to have
on board for an ambulance um standard
type you know saline and different
things that they have and so they that a
particular ambulance may not have gotten
the lock Zone through our distribution
um many of our community service
providers are the ones who are the
recipients so um it may be a community-
based organization we've had churches
we've had schools we've had um service
providers um Welfare Offices many who
have um utilized um the distribution and
been able to access noock Zone that way
so my local Ambulance Service in in
elstead is stocked with that they could
have gotten it either directly or via
one of the part people we partner with
in the community or yeah I can't um I'm
just yeah I can't speak specifically
it's possible um but like I said they um
some the the idea was to have it be a
community response and for Community uh
members for late people to have access
to it and not those who already were
using that um for years and years and
years um but for your specific case you
know we could we could find out if
that's not necessary the good news is
they they have it they stock it and they
use it yeah
yeah all right anything else um in these
accounting
units looks like we'll move on
okay um so now we're at the unnumbered
um similar uh structure as we've had
with the previous bureaus talking about
um everything from Community Education
and awareness up to the crisis level of
service um we have the 2on one we have
the regional public health networks
there are 13 um that we partner with
Public Health in helping support and and
they in turn um are the Regional hub for
these types of services in doing
community assessments and identifying
needs um and they help coordinate
services in their
regions we have the juvenile court
diversion
programs there is prevention and early
intervention and this is starting to go
up the scale so you have assessments you
have youth prevention projects if you've
uh Governor's commission has had a
couple of Youth groups present um on the
funding that they've received and being
able to share with us the work that they
do in their communities it's incredible
so if you ever get a chance to go to
your local middle or high school and see
some of their prevention programs I
highly encourage it um because it's
really um uh hopeful and um positive um
impact on the school the students and
the community ities representative
priest for a
question thank you madam chairman and
thank you for taking my question back to
Community Education and awareness could
you just walk me through the juvenile
court diversion program that you have
I'm not familiar with it yeah so there
are community- based organizations that
have um uh programs that really look at
um youth who are at risk of higher
levels of um criminal justice
involvement and this is a way to
identify them and divert them from um
that that um additional um level
of um involvement um and so um I can get
you more information about the specific
programs um but that's really what that
program is we have several community-
based organizations and they're part of
a network and um this is something that
the DCF field staff um are and the um
and Juvenile Justice I believe
um uh director Nunan um would be able to
talk about the value of these
programs uh peer recovery and uh peers
and Recovery supports so we have two
different peer systems in our division
so we have we talked about the mental
health peer uh uh organizations and we
have them in substance misuse as well
and so these are the known as the
rcos um we have um funding specifically
for those
organizations they um there are I forget
how many locations um I know it says
four contracts here we um have um a
facilitating organization heror care
provides um the uh services for um
administering and subcontracting with
our recovery Community organizations
throughout the state we have recovery
residences this gets back to the
question from representative Stringham
and um about what is our oversight what
are we doing how are we looking at
recovery um and we do uh support those
that are certified there's the recovery
friendly workplace which was a governor
sununu initiative that has taken off and
those are workplaces that have
deliberately um uh gone through a
process to be deemed um recovery
friendly and work with um helping
individuals um maintain their employment
and to help encourage and recruit um
people in recovery um and and help them
um with a recovery effort so that they
can be um productive
workers Community Based Services and
supports um we have the outpatient
treatment we have the doorways uh I want
to talk a little bit we did not do a
slide and it was um I noted it this
morning about the opioid abatement
programs so in addition to the
governor's commission there is now an
opioid abatement um trust fund
commission and that was established when
we started getting settlement money um
with the lawsuits against the
manufacturers and the pharmaceutical
companies um that contributed to the
opioid um epidemic and um You probably
have seen headlines where you know
millions of dollars of settlements and
so we established the state established
a trust fund and there is a commission
um that was legislatively created uh to
be able to oversee those funds and to
make allocations of those funds and so
they've been up and running they also
have a dashboard similar to the
governor's commission dashboard that um
is available um we they make funding
decisions um and have made significant
investments in housing is one area that
they uh we're looking at um they've also
made smaller Community uh investments in
different programs perhaps some have
been mobile Vans um one has been to help
with a purchase of um uh a piece of
property for um
Services uh so they have different ways
of being able to allocate those funds it
is
um not in our budget
and um Nathan can explain
that sure it uh the the the opioid
abatement trust fund it's a dedicated
non-lps and continually appropriated
fund and and that commission uh directs
the department um to utilize that money
and and they they meet regular regularly
and um the department does not indiv
individually make decisions on how those
funds are used that's that's part of the
under statute that's that's how that's
decided representative tarki for a
question this maybe isn't even relevant
our division however in the draft of hb2
there's money from the opio basement
abatement trust fund that's being
directed towards law enforcement at the
northern border um can you I know this
is not your wheelhouse but maybe talk
about those funds and um how they can be
used and if I think in the past um
discussion of using them for law enforce
ment was not a very popular
idea uh we can't comment on that just
because it is out of our wheelhouse I
can say that the purpose um the use of
the funds is dictated by Statute and by
administrative
role okay thank
you representative n valeno Nano we'll
get it the um uh question I have what's
the U Is that a one-off
uh fund I mean the money in that fund
was created by a one-off settlement or
it's a continuing funding source and
then the other question is um same kind
of a question we had on the uh
Governor's uh uh commission fund uh what
is the B roughly the balance in that and
you know what kind of uh budgeting do
you do against you know you know you
like to hold a reserve or what what's
the financial picture on that fund sure
so um we receive uh settlement funds in
different ways depending on the lawsuit
and the success of um how New Hampshire
participated in that lawsuit through our
department of justice and so we've
received one-time funds of you know
small amounts and we've received
multi-year multi-million dollar Awards
so um from the from the settlement so we
have Awards that are expected to be um
made for up to 18 years or 10 years it
depends on the nature of the settlement
and so um it we can project um when
we're going to receive funds based on an
actual settlement and what New Hampshire
has been allocated there are still
pending lawsuits and um we expect that
that will continue for a period of time
and um we're fortunate that the um
Deputy Commissioner of the Department of
Justice is now the chair of the opio de
batement commission and he's able to
give us um updates at each of the
monthly meetings the commission is much
newer than the governor's commission and
um the amount of funds I believe um we
have received somewhere around $50
million and the current balance is
roughly that has not been allocated um
and um it excludes um it already I'm
accounting for this is that the amount
in the budget so if you take all of that
and you look at what's unallocated and
decisions to be made on is about $1
million is the balance okay thank
you all said on this subject all right
proceed
okay I'm not quite sure where I should
go next um but I think we were talking
about um getting up to Residential
Treatment um and housing supports so we
have different
allocations um and in support for
particular programs that have to do with
um Alcohol and Other Drugs um I should
go back what I want to tell you that the
doorways when I talked about that
categorical funding and that's specific
for people with opioid use disorder we
found and we know from the um data that
individuals the the most used um or
misused drug in New Hampshire is alcohol
and so we had people who are appearing
at doorways that were 100% State opioid
response Grant funded and didn't have
the funds to help support those
individuals who only had alcohol use
disorder and no history um of uh opioid
use disorder so the governor's
commission some of their funding helped
support the doorways for those
non sore funded um allowable expenses so
I just wanted to mention that as a way
that we're really crosswalking how we
breed funding and pull together the
pieces so that we don't have those gaps
for People based on our funding
source we help support our treatment
programs we talk about um the
residential treatment inpatient
treatment um we help with room and board
Medicaid doesn't pay for room and board
um when someone enters a course of
treatment in a residential setting so
the state opid response um dollars are
able to um go towards that room and
board
um uh we mentioned um there is that
crisis respit when someone's ready to
enter into treatment but doesn't yet
have an admission or is a waiting
admission so we have those beds
available um we help support the access
point um again that's for people
experiencing a substance use crisis as
well as a mental health crisis or um a
mental health
crisis and um as noted we carry out not
only the administrative functions of the
governor's commission but also of the
opid abatement
commission we went um a little rogue um
on page 52 and don't have a wheel we
just have a
fan um to go through the same the same
steps as we look at um prevention
treatment and Recovery
on page
53 this is um just some examples of the
types of services that fall into those
categories so we have as I mentioned the
regional public health networks and you
can see the regions there's one in your
region um I'm sure you can recognize it
um and we talk about how many people
were um the partners they convene those
Partnerships and those Community Based
organizations and you can see um those
convenings um I will note that the
business Community is part of this um
and an important aspect especially when
we look at recovery friendly
workplaces and the number of uh New
Hampshire residents served the
educational trainings and um the the
youth Le
activities uh
54 so this is looking at um Community
Based
prevention we know how important
prevention is especially in this Arena
and um so that's why you see a lot of
focus a few years ago the governor's
commission recognized that prevention
was lagging behind um everyone
responding to treatment and so they
wanted to invest dollars um in
prevention efforts and actually had um a
very uh specific funding strategy around
Prevention Services so some of that
continues and you can see that
here school-based services on page
55 so we have um representative Neno for
a question sorry to sorry to be a
nuisance here but just a quick question
on of the eight
programs uh um um I I assume that you
couldn't just take eight and divide it
into the
22,000 but so uh what would be the top
couple of programs that account for more
of the individuals and and where what
areas do they
serve so I unless someone behind me
stands up um I'll have to get back to
you on that okay because I assume it's
it's regional or yes yeah those eight
programs yeah yeah okay thank
you I have had staff here to support me
um which has been amazing that they're
sitting here and having to listen and
probably saying ooh o you should have
said this um but it is school vacation
week so we've had um some absences um
and our um our Bureau of drug and
alcohol Services bureau chief was here
earlier I don't believe she's here now
but um she is a prevention Queen and I'm
sure she can answer
um those questions off the top of her
head is somebody
standing no standing
okay all right 55 again school-based
prevention these are school districts
that have um voluntarily and eagerly
adopted programs um to address um
substance misuse student assistant
programs um are coordinators that are at
middle and high schools across the state
um and they're supported um there's um
health and evidence-based curriculum
that is supported multi-tier systems of
support and we have um the Collegiate
tertiary prevention that was an area of
particular interest that we heard over
and over that we were um focusing on
middle and high schools but we're
finding that college Aid students was
that was their first experience
um was substance misuse and that we
needed to um put some support in there
so that's what that's
about representative priest for a
question again as a clarification um the
school-based prevention not only covers
uh Public Schools but also Collegiate
schools in New Hampshire right yes okay
thank
you and a quick question question on the
Collegiate tertiary prevention that's in
conjunction with so again how's that
structured and you know who does that uh
does it touch University of New
Hampshire or or
yeah it right now it's UNH based um with
um the um plan to expand to other
university system uh
campuses um so yeah so so it's a pilot
program at this point essentially yeah I
would say it's pilot with the um plan to
scale up we do plan to scale
up thank
you representative priest for question
yes uh going back to
um the numbers for um alcohol alcoholism
and Other Drug um abuse programs um do
we have any
numbers of what the population is out
there and what
percentage have seek help from
you so I think there are two different
ways of looking at there's the
percentage of individuals who've been
served um it depends on how you look at
being served is it um in a treatment
program is it through recovery housing
through um whatever
so there's one that's one way to look at
it and to slice and dice it I think also
there are the statistics that have been
done based on Anonymous surveys about
how many people actually have alcohol
use disorder or opioid use disorder in
the state and um those are very
different numbers because not everybody
who has a disorder needs or wants um
some type of service that is funded by
the state
and are those numbers available for us
to look at I believe they are um through
our Public Health Partners we have some
um statistics on that and be happy to um
share the link to the website that has
data that you can um that you can uh
look through yourself that would be very
useful thank you you're welcome just a
quick follow-up question on that that
occurred to me so do we partner with I
mean the traditional organization that I
you know kind of grew up with was
Alcoholics Anonymous do we partner with
them or do we fund them or or how to you
know what's the relationship there so um
I we do not fund specifically AA
programs there are AA programs that are
available to people through all of um
throughout our whole system um but I
think the very nature of that particular
program is um the community based um and
um I don't know how to describe it um
but there's no there's no funding
involved um if someone wants to
participate I think that there um is
community support through churches for
locations and through um all the
different uh um public facilities and
other organizations that host them um
but we don't specifically fund AA
programs that's kind of curious because
I've always u u you know the feedback or
anything you've seen on that there's
very effective uh uh program and um you
know it just seems strange that we
wouldn't somehow cooperate with or fund
them other than you know indirectly
through Community groups but anyhow it's
just a side comment many many people
find recovery through such programs and
through other avenues so it is part of
um the the um the the ecosystem and how
people um receive the help that they
need and and that they're able to find
recovery through those
programs thank
you all right we're getting down to the
wire
here um so page
56 this is overdose prevention we've
already talked about um the uh the lock
Zone
distribution and you have the drug desk
by year we didn't add 2024 because the
numbers weren't finalized when we did
this but they continued to go down um
year overy year um we did see the
increase in in 2022 but then we've seen
um pretty remarkable drops since that
time uh we um have attributed that to
all of the programs that are in place
most notably the distribution of nxone
so that we are preventing deaths um when
there is an overdose and access to the
medication for addiction treatment so
that um has been uh an a couple areas
that have been highlighted as
contributing significantly to that
reduction in the overdose
des and just an observation but we've
heard a lot and we see a lot about the
Fentanyl and and and Fentanyl deaths so
I I guess I'm kind of surprised to see
that the statistics I I don't know
that's worked into the STA the
statistics I presume so uh that seems
like a disconnect from you know all the
reports that you hear about the
fentanyl uh crisis and how deadly that
is and I don't think the uh no oxone
doesn't work on fentol does it it
absolutely does oh it does okay there
are other um so it doesn't work for all
drugs um that um may cause an overdose
um but with fentanyl it is effective um
we just had uh the governor's commission
just had a meeting on Friday and we had
a report from the um Department of
Safety and they shared um with us their
state lab um so they have all of the
details about um the samples that they
were given to test and what was found in
those samples so was there meth was
there cocaine was there um you know and
you name the drug and the combination
thereof it's a great report um and so
they they did that can get that to you
point you to their uh website and they
also um provide a monthly drug
monitoring initiative report which takes
information from a variety of sources
and they get it from EMS so the
Statewide EMS system they're able to
pull data from and they know how many uh
across the state how many um responses
there were to individuals who had
overdosed um and um the and then you
take the state lab information that's
included in that report you take the
treatment admissions that are in that
report so it's a wealth of information
that is provided about the current
status of what's Happening happening um
and what we're always looking at and the
state police um and the and the
department of safety really talked about
um what they're seeing on the street and
what's up and coming and uh the concerns
that may arise um as they different
combinations of drugs that are um out
and put into distribution and are of
great concern so we partner really
closely with the Department of
Safety I I guess the other one is
probably a Mis conception on my part is
just that and there's been a lot of
discussion in This this term about
marijuana and medical marijuana or you
know legalizing marijuana and maybe it's
a misconception on my part but I was you
know my understanding was that the
marijuana isn't the same marijuana that
I may have uh experienced when I was
College age and that it's uh sometimes
laced with a lot of other stuff so is
that is that uh a misconception or is it
uh uh some aspects of marijuana use that
overlap with the uh whole uh mixture of
other things that are out there yeah and
the um and the people from the state lab
did present some of that data what they
indicated was when you look at it
because it's no longer a criminal
penalty um for
um marijuana or for cannabis that
they're not testing as often for that
but it does come up in that um poly use
of um of different drugs and and Lace um
but um I'm not I'm not the expert on
that particular I understand thank you
yeah um going off of that there hasn't
been a whole lot of talk about smoking
in general uh in your department whereas
we've reached all other sorts of topics
any remarks regarding
that um so that is um something that we
we have um had efforts around um I would
defer to associate commissioner um Trish
Tilly who is here um from a public
health perspective where there are
programs around that we also have had um
efforts around our community mental
health system because individuals with
uh mental health condition have um been
known to have an increase uh risk and
associated with smoking um and with
tobacco um but um if if Trish is here
and she wants to comment but um it is
something that um is certainly on the
radar sure miss Tilly if You' just like
to have a seat hi again and thank you
Patricia Tilly associate commissioner um
at the department thanks for that
question I think we can dive into that a
lot more on Tuesday when public health
comes and talks to the committee our
tobacco prevention and control program
who in the division of Public Health
Services we've had a long partnership
with the division for Behavioral Health
as as director Fox had noted because of
the disproportionality of people with
mental health or behavioral health
conditions and tobacco use and so we
have strategies to be able to connect
that both um in Quitline Services as
well as just sort of the structural
environmental around having appropriate
tobacco related policies in um among the
different programs that that serve
people with behavioral health conditions
so it sort of comes out from both ways
the issue of course um many people have
been thinking about is vaping um so our
tobacco program also covers vaping in
particular for adolescent use and we saw
that dramatic rise of vaping during the
pandemic we're happy to see that the
youth rate of vaping has come down it's
still too high but we did have a peak in
about 2021 and we're on the other side
of that now but there are lots of
unknown questions about the impact of of
vaping those chemicals the nicotine use
and what that might mean for um
addiction later on so more to come on
Tuesday thank you we'll look forward to
that on Tuesday budget work session
division of Public Health representative
tersi for a question thank you
um we've it's my understanding that the
um progress we've made with overdose
prevention can be tied to Granite
Advantage um and the Medicaid supports
that we have for people with substance
use disorder um because we've seen the
numbers drop um as your chart indicates
right here and I guess my question goes
to you mentioned um it it it points to
Noone access but also medications for
treatment so I guess the conversation
again on the um Medicade changes to both
the prescription copays doubling um and
just simple access to the Medicaid
Program um raises some alarm for me that
we may have a setback can we talk a
little bit about how someone who um
doesn't have coverage or can't afford uh
their pharmaceutical copay would be able
to access medication for their treatment
of substance use
disorder and how that may affect the
overall
picture so um when I talked about where
in actually this ties into the um slide
that we're about to go to when talking
about treatment so the department does
contract with uh treatment providers and
as part of that contract it covers non
billable Medicaid billable services and
so it ALS so there are um people from
the um federal poverty line of 138 to
400%
that are covered by these contracts as
well th as those that are um uninsured
and
underinsured and so the providers are
able to through demonstration of the
need bill against those uh
contracts um to be able to fill those
gaps I am unsure of the impact that a
change in expansion would have other
than when we first had these contracts
there was not um a benefit um for um sud
Services through Medicaid until um the
ACA was passed in
2014 and be so before we paid a um
almost all of the services were paid
through these contracts over time we
were able to shift what we were paying
for for these treatment providers
because of the Medicaid coverage um
people were covered and they were able
to Bill Medicaid rather than bill
against the contract so we saw a shift
in the way um that we are paying for
those
Services um and we would expect that
there may be a shift back so that's a
tiny bit of um better news than what I
thought but is there a ceiling on those
contracts like is there a way those
could get maxed out the ceiling is met
today we we ask for the funds and they
expend them so it is all dependent on um
the allocations that are made here the
Appropriations okay so slide
57 you can see the numbers here the
numbers that are served these are not
every single treatment provider in the
state of New Hampshire these are the
ones that responded to a request for
proposals and have entered into contract
with the state um so those this wouldn't
be reflective of all um providers in the
state um there are some that don't
accept um Medicaid and choose they may
accept Medicaid but they choose not to
contract with the state representative
Neno for a question yeah very quick
question is this this Behavior Health
also cover gambling addiction I mean
that's another I it's you know I just
kind of struck me as being notable by
its absence on this and then is there a
separate uh are the casinos funding some
kind of a separate fund for gambling
addiction and what is what is that and
what what's in it so I'm not sure if the
LBA wants to comment on that
um sorry I was in the midst of
responding to an email what was the
problem sorry about
that I I can let you know so um he he
was asking about um the gambling and
whether we um if there's an allocation
through the state um to address um
addiction to gambling and I know there
is um it at one time I believe was going
to be attached or was attached to the
department but now it is overseen by the
Lottery Commission I believe okay um I'm
not sure about that but I can check with
um Mickey landrian who does division one
so he would know about that through the
lottery divis uh through the Lottery
Commission so I can get you an answer to
that but it is a it is a behavioral
health issue I mean for sure so I mean I
would just as I said it was notable by
its absence from anywhere any mention of
it all in the in the presentation and
whether or not you all are dealing with
it with any programs or or that's a
totally separate uh um there is funding
um and it's does go I believe to the
Lottery Commission and it um funds
programs for that addressing
that I think it was the source of funds
um that um really contributed it to
being it um with um Lottery versus the
department yeah but I mean that's been a
that's been an expanding kind of a
program was Lottery and then it went to
you know the casinos and and my
understanding is that the the the
governor's proposed budget had money in
there for slot machine a pretty big
chunk of money in the uh in the budget
uh towards the in the the end of the
second year of the bium I think 127
million that's exactly the estimate
right that was the estimate that kind of
U uh was used to balance the uh balance
the governor's
budget
so right so I think that you'll get the
information about where it is in the
budget and what it funds and and how
that's um what percentage and and that
kind of
thing but it is something that probably
you have on the radar to be dealing with
on the behavior health side
yes proceed okay so we are closing in um
the recovery we've talked about that a
little bit we have the peer recovery
support programs um and you can see how
many individuals that they've served um
the recovery
residences um the ones that were
certified I talked about the certifying
body um and that assures that um quality
standard and then the recovery friendly
workplace now oh State opioid response
is another separate slide here we've
talked a lot about it um sure I just
want to back representative it's me go
um what is a what kind of give me a feel
for what a recovery friendly workplace
constitutes absolutely so there is a
program in which um a business um can be
deemed a recovery friendly workplace it
is um I'm waiting for someone to get up
behind
me um no such luck no that's okay I
don't need them to but I heard footsteps
um so it's a business that wants to be
able to re attract and maintain um staff
and as you know there have been Staffing
shortages across a whole bunch of
different um Fields including
manufacturing and um in health care
settings and by deeming themselves and
going through a process where they go
through um a checklist to make sure that
they have the right components in place
to be part of this program um they're
able to um advertise that and then uh
really help and give that assistance to
um the people who um work for them as
they so that they don't lose a job so
that there's not the absenteeism so
there is that active um process in
helping them in their recovery and
maintain recovery um new the state of
New Hampshire um the department is a
recovery friendly workplace um but there
are many businesses and there's a long
list of businesses that um are part of
this
program okay thank
you all right State opioid response I
think we've talked a lot about this um
in um scattered throughout all of the
programming because we have braided
funding and um have built upon efforts
that have um either we started by um the
that particular funding source or that
we're able to um enhance and support and
augment uh with that funding source so
the idea of the doorways um they're
strategically located in nine locations
so that it is easy for people to access
services within an hour any other state
or populated state you'd say an hour I'm
not going to take an hour but New
Hampshire we know an hour is pretty
close um and that there is an Inc um an
increase in standardization of
services um and that um the go main goal
is to
decrease um the overdose deaths um so
that is something that we're measuring
against and um we fund as I said I think
it's about 30 uh contracts um that are
going through that uh cont Contracting
process right now we have the doorways
that are open during typical um daytime
hours they're in hospitals um Hospital
based
locations um and then we have an after
hours uh so that if someone's in crisis
not only could they have mobile crisis
and call that they also have the
clinical coverage where they can get
some um supports until they can get to
the doorway physically the next day so
we do that through
211 um again medications comes up here
we are able to support um those
medications for treatment we have a
collaboration yesterday I was before the
executive council with anou with
corrections so that we're able to um
support the services that they provide
to individuals who are transitioning to
the community um so that includes nck
Zone training on Nock zone for staff um
and um some other services that are able
to be provided by
doc um recovery housing crisis respit
we've talked a lot about some of uh
these services and um we do have a
relationship and are able to provide
some assistance to the drug overdose
fatality review commission which looks
at cases typically um that have been
closed and brings the parties that are
involved in that particular uh death
together so that they're able to learn
from that process and to be able to make
any policy changes that are needed um so
that we can do a better job as we
go and the last
slide going just reviewing our
prioritized
needs so as you can see we did um very
well with our prioritized needs we um
are very fortunate to continue to
receive the support from the governor
and hopefully the legislature as we uh
carry out the functions and the needs of
individuals with behavioral health
conditions we had the
um the um uncompensated care the $5
million in each of those uh each fiscal
year um that was noted the shelter rate
increases that were um done in this uh
State fiscal year and those will
continue to carry forward if they remain
in the budget um to keep at that
$27 um per bed per DM um we have the
Waypoint uh shelter that was
funded one area that you'll be hearing
um more about I'm sure from uh the
community is Guardianship
Services um so we had asked for
additional
uh funding to
increase um the um number um that
they're able to serve as well as the
rates and we that was not
funded and then um we had as we
referenced 1573 HB 1573 that we receive
some funding that funding will stretch
um through the bayum but not for the
last 6 months so that was a prioritized
need that we put in to um be able to
cover that last 6 months for that
increased oversight of residential
programs and um so that that was um put
into this
budget the cross divisional with um DCF
we talked about the provider rates and
whether there was an increase for the
rates um and so the um rates were not
funded but the um amount that we need to
make up for a loss of federal funds um
was in part supported um with half the
amount that we asked for we asked for 18
million and we received 9 million
representative priest has recognized for
a
question thank you Madame chairman uh
and thank you for taking my question
going back to the guardian Services
could you just give us a brief
explanation of what that is sure so
there are individual ual who um are go
through a process of being determined to
need a guardian to make decisions on
their behalf and so in the behavioral
health field and in with um individuals
with um intellectual disorders they are
appointed Guardians and so the Guardians
um are provided through um two contracts
that we have um and so um that's an area
that um is typically
underfunded and uh needs needs
support would one of those Services be
cassa that you cassa is a very very
important um part of the child
protection and child welfare system that
is not covered here representative Nanos
repres recognize for question that's
court appointed or is that's outside of
the courts or U is it a combination of
both um I will defer to that I believe
that it is um deemed you have to um be
con you have to go to court to get a
guardianship so if I had an elderly
parent and I wanted to be their Guardian
um if they didn't voluntarily um you
know petition or ask for a guardian then
I would go to the court and ask for
guardianship but I if I have that wrong
um I'll make sure that we correct that
so I'm just curious on on the funding of
that is is it you know um and I don't
have a a great understanding of that
whole process because we've never had to
go through it but if it's court
appointed the the costs any other places
in the state budget where that's covered
legal services or or is it entirely in
this uh area of the
budget we we we we have we have other
costs throughout our budget that are the
result of court-based decisions I mean
children entering the dcyf system is a
good example earlier we were looking at
an accounting unit that had um
assessments that that are required so
it's it's certainly not that unusual to
have have a cost be be driven
externally okay
thank all right I think that concludes
our presentation for today there is a
lot of information that's in my head
that didn't come out of my mouth and I'm
sure you have a lot of questions that
you hadn't yet um articulated so be
happy to um answer and respond to the
questions you did ask today and to be
available for any other questions that
may arise thank you very much for that
very thorough and detailed presentation
we truly appreciate the time you took
not only to present it but to parot we
are very mindful of the hours that go
into uh a presentation like this it's
like I used to tell my students you know
you see the teacher in the classroom but
that's not all they do there's a lot of
behind the scenes that have to be
appreciated in terms of the time and
talent that it takes to actually appear
and you have done that so thank you very
much representative priest is recognized
Madam chairman I would like to kind of
second what you have said Thank you
again and Miss Fox and and Mr White very
thorough um program and thank you for
all the services that you and your
division are doing thank
you if there are members with us today
who would like to make comments what
have you you are welcome to do that uh
please give our presenters some time to
clear and then come up and do
make your name and who you represent
clear thank
you
welcome thank you representative Mooney
um I'm uh Jim Monahan with the DuPont
group and I'm uh though I represent and
work with a lot of folks uh in the
Medicaid system and we'll be here quite
a bit I did want to focus a bit on my um
if in case of listening on YouTube my
favorite client uh the be the community
Behavior Health Association which is the
10 Community Mental Health Centers um
first of all let me just Echo what the
committee has already said um you know
we really see the work that we do with
the department and the bureau as a
partnership uh the 10 Community Mental
Health Centers care for about 50,000
people a year the vast majority of those
are uh medic the vast majority the
funding for that comes through Medicaid
and um our working relationship with the
Department is excellent and so I
appreciate uh just as you have the work
that uh ker and the team put into the
presentation today um I'll be relatively
brief I just want to highlight the
committee to three things three things
that we'll be asking for in the context
of the budget above and beyond what
you've seen in the funded priorities um
uh the first is uh we are joining with
other um uh providers in the New
Hampshire Healthcare Workforce Coalition
uh in supporting uh a 3% rate increase
for Medicaid providers in the upcoming
budget uh many in this committee might
know that a lot of work was put into a
pretty significant adjustment in rates
um in the last budget um our hope as we
move forward is to come in with modest
and needed rate increases each budget
cycle so we're not here in Desperate Str
rates every 10 years and so we did
survey the uh provider Community um
across the 23 rate cycles that we went
through in all the spreadsheets two
years ago uh and remarkably found that
with very few exceptions many felt as
though the 3% was what was needed and
didn't ask to go above and beyond that
um uh in addition to that uh the
Community Mental Health Centers have
legislation pending in the Senate with
an appropriation on it that deals some
with some very important housing issues
um as um director Fox pointed out on
number of occasions with you all uh for
many of the folks in Medicaid that we
care for uh room and board are not um
Medicaid allowable expenses and so
oftentimes the um Community Mental
Health Centers that run those programs
have to struggle to put them together so
there is a Senate bill that asks for
general fund appropriation to support
that activity uh and to be honest with
you um I do not remember the name number
um but we'll get it to you my expect and
it it had a favorable recommendation in
Senate Finance um but I presume that
they will um as With Many Items U pass
it out a committee and table it awaiting
the work waiting for the the bill to
come over the Senate you'll see that
whole laundry list I expect but uh our
hope is this one is on top um the last
point that I wanted to um talk about
today is the issue of uncompensated care
um as you heard from director Fox
uh in the governor uh Provisions have
been made in the uh House Bill one as
introduced uh to fund some of the
uncompensated Care uh that the community
mental health centers are experiencing
uh the material that uh Mr Ripple passed
out um is a part of a work product that
was we undertook from the Community
Mental Health Center is to figure out uh
we know we have uncompensated care but
where is it coming from um and so the uh
the D spreadsheet organizes it by the 10
Community ment Health Centers and then
the the document you have here which is
a little data it's outlined on the in as
a November document the first part of it
describes uh what is driving the
uncompensated care uh and it outlines uh
the sectors which are outlined in the
spreadsheet here and they range from
underfunding of Medicaid associated with
the Medicaid spend down
programs um uh concerns at the mental
health centers are experiencing with
regard to uh folks that have commercial
insurance but can't afford and don't pay
their co-pays and co-
Insurance um which as you know uh from
the uh state law that you all have
enacted and continue to act that the
Community Mental Health Centers like
some other safety net agencies must care
for folks that come in the door
regardless of their ability to pay so
we're seeing
increasingly primarily the increasing
coming from the commercial payers um who
have very high co-pays of co- Insurance
um but of probably more significant
importance they don't pay for necessary
services that are the services that are
provided to Medicaid uh recipients so
what we're um seeing if you look at the
spreadsheet that I gave you um in the uh
far right hand column the very top
number and the very bottom is number uh
is that in 202 24 we experienced a $15.4
million uncompensated care hit to the
Community Mental Health Centers which as
you can see amounted to a
12% um uh differential when as compared
to our Medicaid payments what's
remarkable there is if you look at from
2021 to 2024 uh it has doubled uh it's
gone from 6% to
12% um uh we are attempting to try to
resolve some of the um private payer
issues uh and had filed legislation in
the Senate uh that um I I suspect is
probably not going to advance this
session which would have charged an
assessment to the commercial providers
who are not um uh uh um paying for
necessary care through the commercial
products uh we have uh uh failed to yet
to get the support of the Department of
Insurance or the or the insurers for
this approach but want to continue to
work on that
um so among uh the uh things that we are
working on it may be coming back to this
committee with is a proposal that would
set up a mechanism at the Department of
Insurance to try to address some of the
commercial carrier uncompensated care
but in doing so we might a we might ask
you to frontload the uncompensated Care
number that's in the budget so rather
than doing five and five frontload it to
10 to stabilize things for the community
mental to Health Centers and in that uh
in that that year of stability we will
be trying to work with the Department of
Insurance to improve the situation with
regard to commercial
coverage um and then the last thing I
want to do is um I'm going to leave this
for the committee and leave it on the
table so that as you look at proposals
that come before you you look through
the I was going to write uncompensated
Care on this but through the
uncompensated care lens that we are all
looking for so I know that there will be
uh more comment on this next week but
when you take a look at some of the
issues proposed in the governor's budget
which you know we're we're still
evaluating with regard to copays and and
premium contributions uh and the work
requirement issues that are around we
want to be very conscious that um that
the impact of those Provisions are not
to create more uncompensated care for
the mental health centers recognizing
there a state law that says we have to
care for folks regardless of their
ability to pay if they lose their
coverage because of administrative
burdens around a work requirement or
because the family is unable to pay uh a
premium uh the impact of that typically
falls to the provider and for providers
that can't um deny care for people it
really just get gets absorbed as
additional uncompensated care
so those are uh um uh things we'll be
hoping to work with the committee on
over the next several weeks and in uh
several months when we bring the Senate
into it but I wanted to thank you for
the opportunity to alert you to those
today thank you very much yes be sure to
leave that magnifying glass in a place
where we can all find it right there any
questions yes representative n valano
Nano
Nano you see representative the deeper I
am in concentration and the materials in
front of me the uh the more likely it is
I may mispronounce no problem you're
closer than a lot of
in-laws um a question uh is U
transparency in pricing across you know
for for for procedures U all kinds of
services that are provided in the
medical health field which I think
contribute to the uncompensated you know
it's an uneven distribution some places
charge X some charge I and I assume that
that contributes to a level of
uncompensated care depending on where
you go for the for the service whether
you have insurance or you don't have
insurance and I'm just wondering whether
you U uh see potentially some of the
reforms that are that are kind of
requiring transparency in so you know
upfront what you're paying for a service
or a drug or that sort of thing would
that play a role in helping to alleviate
uh some of the issue that we have here
it's an interesting perspective I think
you're looking for the perspective of
the person who's purchasing insurance
and whether or not there's transparency
in the coverage and the in the cost well
it's how you're how you're you know you
have an insurance policy and you decide
to go to one place or the other and
there's a difference you know I've seen
it in my own insurance coverage
depending on where where you go the cost
of the same service may be different at
different uh uh different hospitals or
for different
providers um and that in turn I think
contributes to how much of it is funded
you know uh funded or unfunded you know
in network out of network there's a
whole host of arms and legs on on this
uh thing that I I would think contribute
to a certain extent greater or lesser uh
on the uncom so-called uncompensated
care aspect of this yeah I think our
first look at the uncompensated care
piece and the commcial commercial
environment are uh services and codes
that all commercial insurers don't cover
uh and uh but beyond that I think and
this is something commissioner bonc
deserves to try to figure out which is
in uh I think I'm getting to your
question in in in some plans where
there's a very high
deductible uh or there are different
levels of service that what the
Community Mental Health Center would be
reimburse for the services could be
different based upon the insurance
product that that the uh the purchaser
acquires well not just the insurance
product but what the providers are
charging I think there's differences uh
there as well uh and and also it comes
down to how things are coded I think
we've all run into the case where you
know you go to one provider and they're
better at coding uh stuff in terms of an
understanding of how the insurance
situation works and those that that that
aren't as skilled at doing the coding
result in different levels of uh
compensation and then in turn
uncompensated uh uncompensated care yeah
I think that's probably the the the um a
level of the uncompensated Cure issue
but what we're trying to work out within
with the insurers is let's get a let's
all get to the same playing field so
that there's an agreement that you're
going to pay for a certain service and
then it' be up to the
individual Community Mental Health
Center to negotiate that rate well I
come to the to the transparency issue on
it's not just what are you going to
compensate but what are you going to
charge you know if I have a choice
between you know two places that charge
the charge different things for
essentially the same product I can make
a judgment on quality and I can make a
judgment on on price but as it is you
know if I need uh I need treatment I I
go or and I don't really look at the
cost uh consideration because when you
need the care you need the care but it
would would be helpful to know that you
had an alternative uh maybe same quality
lower
cost but I'm I'm just I'm just throwing
that out there because I think it isn't
just a um uh an issue of how much the
insurance company is going to pay and
getting them all on the same page it's
the it's the cost and the charge side of
this as
well so there are two two components of
that at least in my view and in in my
personal experience we're often quite
careful in the way we work with the
Community Mental Health Center is
because we don't want to be um engaged
in any activity where the the center
should be negotiating those rates with
the provider um uh so I don't disagree
with you I just think that's typically
the you know kind of the business side
of the of the community M Health Center
well this is all this is all business
isn't
it um right but it's contractual
business that has to be operated
according to the regulatory rules so you
know I I'll leave it as that okay thank
you thank you all set thank you very
much anyone else from the public wishing
to address div Vision three again if you
could just clearly state your name and
who you represent would be
appreciated good afternoon members of
the committee my name is Kate fry I'm
the vice president of advocacy at new
Futures and I'm Emma savenia I'm the
children's Behavioral Health policy
coordinator at new futures um we will be
very brief and I want to thank the
committee for offering an opportunity
for uh public comment also want to thank
the uh department for their very
thorough presentation new Futures uh
works on policy issues on health and
wellness and uh we have several buckets
of work that will follow and we'll
probably talk to you about during this
process but today um we are highlighting
parts of the division of Behavioral self
services um regarding the governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs
and children's Behavioral Health I just
do want to support um the uh Governor's
commission line in the budget we are
very pleased to see that the governor
did um fully fund that at the 5% level
of gross profits from alcohol um because
of that we will be able to continue some
really important work that we have um
undergone in the state regarding um
substance use disorder prevention
treatment and Recovery um and as you
heard from uh director Fox there is a
very clear oversight process by the
governor's Commission of the expenditure
of those funds and by the department so
again we support that 5% um allocation
in the governor's
budget and I would just like to
highlight the importance of the
children's system of care line item um
you heard in depth this morning about
that and how um it helps children not
just in their youth but long longterm
Better Health outcomes across the
lifespan I'd also like to just
underscore the importance of that
children's Behavioral Health Resource
Center that you heard about um not only
does it provide resources to families in
New Hampshire um through the website but
it also provides um important technical
assistance to uh providers to help train
up our Workforce and be able to provide
those critical services to families
across the grite
state thank you both would you take
questions if there are
any questions for members of division
3 all set thank you very much for your
input and
thought last call well what just one
quick one if you have cards or you could
leave information you know so I have it
for the record as
well okay I think we're all set uh this
division 3 meets again on Monday March
3rd at 10 o'clock in this room it's a
budget work session on the division of
economic stability uh next week is very
busy for the division we're here on
March 3rd which is Monday March 4th
March 5th March 6th is a house session
day March 10th March 11 March
12 all of the times that the divisions
meet is at 10:00 with the exception of
March 5th that's 9:00 a.m.
anything further from the members of
division 3 or anyone else around the
table I thank you all very much
hopefully your commutes home will be
better than your commutes here and we
will see you again thank you all we'll
close this work session